I'm here with Mr Beast the brilliant
Mastermind behind some of the most
popular videos ever created
do you think you'll ever make a video
that gets 1 billion views I think maybe
one of the videos we've already made
might get a billion views which one do
you think probably like the the squid
game video with enough time I mean it's
only a year old and it's already on 300
million or some of the newer ones we've
done have gotten like 100 million views
in a month
um so those four projected over 10 years
because YouTube's not going anywhere
probably one of those so over time they
don't necessarily Plateau what's
interesting we're literally jumping
right now I love it it's good um so I
I'm a firm believer that it's much
easier to hypothetically get 10 million
views on one video than a hundred
thousand on a hundred and part of why
it's much easier in my opinion is like
if you make a really good video it's
just so Evergreen and it never dies
because YouTube when you open up YouTube
and look at the videos they're just
serving you whatever they think you'll
like the best you know and so if you
just make a great video and it's
constantly just above every other video
you know even two years down the road
then they'll just keep serving it never
stop you know which is why it's much
easier to make one great video than a
bunch of mediocre ones what about 1
billion subscribers you've uh passed
PewDiePie's the most subscribed to
YouTube channel uh when do you think you
get a billion uh let me do some math
real quick so we're on 120 what do you
think about this no I don't honestly I
because one thing you'll find if you
want to gain subscribers if you want to
get views if you want to make money and
almost any metric in this uh video
creation space if you want something it
all comes back to okay well then just
make great videos so instead of like
focusing on all these arbitrary vanity
metrics I just kind of focus on the one
thing that gets me all that which is
make good videos but and that I do think
we will when they hit a billion
subscribers I don't have a plan on going
anywhere even though we're only on 120
million right now on the main Channel I
think like we're doing around 10 million
a month now and
um YouTube Just yeah I just don't see it
going anywhere and I don't see any
reason why I'd ever get burnt out or
quit so I think with enough time yes I
wanted to ask you those family friendly
questions before I go to the doc
question so now we have dark questions
right now but if you wanted to hook them
you would start off with the dark
questions that's how you get them okay
well let me ask you about the uh a
Twitter poll you posted a ten thousand
dollar death poll he tweeted if someone
offered you ten thousand dollars but if
you take it a random person on Earth
dies would you take the ten thousand
dollars and uh forty five percent of
people said yes that's at least at the
time I checked 850 000 people committing
murder
for just 8.5 billion dollars in total so
uh what do you learn about human nature
from that that's a a good question
um honestly this is like late at night
when I threw that up too I was just like
huh this will be a funny thing I assumed
it'd be 90 known like 10 yes but there
are a lot of serious people
um for you guys listening I just did
this random Twitter poll I was like
would you take 10 grand if it meant
someone random in the world died and a
lot of the replies on this week were
like hell yeah why not and I was just
not expecting that
um and so I don't really know I mean I
feel like your take would be better than
mine was it disturbing to you surprising
to you a little bit Yeah but I you know
obviously a lot of people were trolling
but I actually you know you read through
those replies I do think like 10 of them
were like dead serious well I think
sometimes the trolling and the laws
reveal a thing we're too embarrassed to
admit about the darker aspects of our
nature so I don't know if you listen to
Dan Carlin's Hardcore History Podcast he
has a episode on painful payment which
he describes throughout history how
humans have been really attracted to
watching The Suffering of others so
um public executions all that kind of
stuff and he believes that's in all of
us that for example if something like a
YouTube or a different platform
stream to public execution or streamed
the torture of another human being
a lot of people would uh say that's
deeply unethical but they will still
tune in and watch and that where we're
attracted to that drama and especially
the most extreme versions of that drama
and so I think part of the laws
reveals something that's actually true
in that poll that like your answer is so
much better than mine do you think about
that maybe even with the squid game like
so I think how many how many views does
this game currently have 300 million
yeah something like this
so
just imagine
a thought experiment how many views that
video would get if it was like real yes
because I mean YouTube was like We'll
turn the blind out we won't take it down
yeah I mean it I've obviously I probably
have billions of views how do you think
you will die and do you think you'll be
during a video probably doing something
dumb like going to space when I'm in the
older like trying to go to Mars or
something like that I know for a fact it
won't be on a video every video we do
with safety experts and stuff like that
so it's not really risk but
um yeah I could see myself like you know
after a million people go to Mars or
something like that I'd probably be like
you know what let's go and and something
like that maybe so not in the name of a
video just no for the holiday heck no
are you open to taking risks when you
shoot videos you just went to Antarctica
I mean like you're you're putting
yourself in the line a little bit right
of course but you know we we've had that
video in the works for three years and
then we consult with tons of experts
radar the entire path we're gonna walk
beforehand to see if there's crevasses
so we know there's no crevasses we do
training we consult with experts and we
have survival guides there with us and
you know monitor to the weather and
everything so it's like any variable
that where we could get harmed we just
pre-planned for it same thing with
buried alive like I had David Blaine
spent a week underground and so I
consulted with him and consulted with
basically anyone who ever buried
themselves alive you know the coffin we
used to bury me we did so many tests
like that coffin was buried 10 times
before I was you know for a little way
longer than 50 hours it tested the
airflow and everything to the point
where I was safer in that coffin
underground than I was above ground like
so we just tend to just not leave
anything up to chance you know
another strange question then
so you've recorded these videos
to yourself you know five years ten
years from now have you recorded a video
that's to be released once you die
well first off I am just glad that not
every one of your questions have to do
with like views or things like that it's
nice getting different questions so this
is this is good um no seriously stuck
but it's fine because a lot of people
just be like how much money do you make
you know it's just something I just
everything's always about money now for
when people talk to me so it's nice
um but for the videos I made uh for you
guys who probably don't follow me too
closely when I had 8 000 subscribers and
I was a teenager I filmed a bunch of
videos and scheduled them years in the
future and I said I'd filmed one where I
was like hi me in a year and the video
went up a year later and it was just
like hey I think you'll have 100 000
subscribers and then I did one where I
was like hire me in five years I was
like Hey in five years I think you'll
have a million and then one that hasn't
come out yet but it comes out in two
years is was high me in 10 years and I
try to predict 10 years later how many
Subs I'd have that's what he's referring
to and yes there there are some that are
scheduled like 20 years in the future
and so if I don't die I'll just move
them up and I remember because I filmed
these though like seven years ago but uh
it was I remember saying a line like you
know if I'm dead then I'm currently just
in a coffin and like whatever blah blah
because the only way the video go up is
if I'm not alive and if I'm not alive
then I won't be able to push back to
schedule upload date so go public
automatically yes and so yeah I have a
couple of those uh like if I knew I was
gonna die of like
cancer or something I had like three
months to live I would Vlog every day
I'd film so many videos and then I would
just schedule upload a video a week for
like the next five years so it's like
I'm still alive and I would completely
act like I'm still alive and everything
and I think something like that would be
cool
it's I don't know why but I've
fantasized not fantasize but I've
dreamed about that a lot like I don't
know if if I only had 30 days to live
what would I do and for me I would try
to make like a decades worth of content
and schedule upload it so they
automatically go public in the future
and so it's just like I never died I'm
just there
yeah it's a kind of immortality but it's
also kind of troll on the concept of
time yeah that you can die in the
physical space but persist in the
digital space I actually I recorded a
video like that because I had some
concerns and I just thought it's also a
good exercise to do a video would like
to be released if I die
and it was actually a really interesting
exercise it's cool like it shows like
what you really care about I guess it's
like writing a will but when you're
younger you don't think about that kind
of stuff but exactly mine was just dumb
yeah like I'm bones in a coffin yeah
yours is probably so serious no it's fun
actually what you realize it's like
there's no point to be serious at this
point it's a weird thing I guess you've
done this but it's a weird thing to
address the world when you the
physically you is no longer there so
like you know this would only be
released if you're no longer there
exactly that's a weird exercise you know
what's funny of all the people listening
to this yeah you know we're probably the
only two people that have made videos
for when we die it's like such a niche
thing and the fact that we're bonding
over it's kind of funny I think people
should think about doing that it's not
just about YouTube it's also social
media because think about it
like there's going to be a last tweet
and the last I don't know Facebook post
their last Instagram post
and uh
yeah I feel like there's some aspects
that's meditative to just even
considering making a post like that and
also it's a way for your the people that
love you to kind of like celebrate do
you think that would help them cope or
not like if someone randomly watching
this did film a video you know for if
they accidentally died in some freak
accident to be given to their family do
you think that would and it was like a
genuine I think it would really help I
mean it depends because like how would
you even intro that like hey Mom if
you're seeing this you know it means I'm
probably dead yeah exactly that's how
you enjoy it that's the opener oh I just
want you to know yeah I guess yeah and I
guess you could say in a kind of funny
way but um and just talk about the
things that you that mean a lot to you
because otherwise you're at the risk of
the last post you have is like like I
don't know talking [ __ ] about like
McDonald's McDonald's
exactly and then you're dead that's it
100 years
I don't know this I I do recommend it
it's uh like the stoics meditate on
death every day in the same way you kind
of meditate in your death when you make
a video like that because it's actually
not just even talking to yourself it's
talking to the world
and it like for some reason at least for
me they made it very concrete that
there's going to be an end
and I'm like
it's almost it's over for me if I'm
making the video it's over for me it's
just an interesting thought experiment I
recommend people
um uh try it okay uh from Are You Afraid
Of Death By the way yes I I
it's hard because
like what if you just die and then you
just see nothing forever you know yeah
the nothingness it just Fades the
Blackness and you're just like that for
trillions upon trillions to billion
squared years and it's just it's scary
but also before you're born you don't
remember those what x amount of years
either so
um that gives me a little Comfort but no
it's definitely very scary something I'd
rather not think about until I'm like
80. I'll deal with that problem then I I
don't know if I told you this but I'm
kind of hopeful that someone like Elon
or one of these like freak smart people
will just like be like you know what
screw it I'm gonna figure out a way
where we can slow down aging get it
where you know we can live to be two 300
years old and just like set their sights
on that and then just kind of save us so
it'd be really nice like it's it's
almost absurd to think that in our
lifetime they won't figure out a way to
just even slightly slow down aging where
we could live to be like 120 or 130 and
then that extra time they won't figure
out somewhere we could live to be 200.
like obviously not Immortal but I don't
I don't see how in my lifetime the life
expectancy doesn't just expand well it
also could be that the immortality is
achieved in the digital realm like it
could be a long be long after you're
gone there's a Mr Beast run by Chad gbt
type system exactly yeah that consumes
everything I ever said everything I ever
wrote and thought I don't want that I
want to live what are you smart people
out there figure it out I'll keep you
entertained but I need you to figure out
how to keep me alive give me until 200.
that will make me happy
well that's that's funny who owns the
identity of of Mr Beast wants the
physical body is gone
like is it illegal to create another Mr
Beast that's Chad GPT based I don't know
what the laws are on that yeah like I
mean once I'm done I don't care well but
you just said you did care I mean there
could be a AI like many Mr beasts that
are created after after you're gone yeah
I mean that would be cool to be able to
like train up a model and and let them
loose so my content lives on I guess
yeah yeah but it somehow feels like it
diminishes the video you contribute yeah
yeah it's an authentic but it's also
there's there's some aspect to the
finiteness of the art
being necessary for it yeah I want the
second that thing starts spamming out
videos the videos lose all meaning and
it's pointless and it's a money grab
if you run YouTube for uh how long
should you run it for a year uh how
would you change it how would you
improve it it's hard because you know
obviously I'm biased because we're doing
really well but I feel like when I open
up YouTube on my television I get the
videos I want to watch I don't
I don't know I don't I don't ever open
it and wonder like what are these what
are these 10 videos on my home page when
I click on video messages I don't ever
wonder what these are like I I and maybe
it's because I'm very adamant about like
the kind of videos I watch and I try not
to watch videos that I don't want to get
recommended more because I just that's
how I think but I'm very happy with how
it is at the moment I think one thing
though that I just hate with the passion
is the comment section on YouTube it's
just so bad
um but that I know that's not something
that's gonna 10x the growth of the
platform but if you think about it you
go to Reddit to read comments and
somehow like that you know usually the
top 20 posts uh on a popular Reddit post
are not spam you know what I mean like
have you ever clicked on something on
the front page of Reddit and then most
upvoted reply to it is like go check out
my site right here and it's like trying
to escape me out of a thousand dollars
yeah yeah I can't even think of one
instance I've ever had that happen so
like Reddit it's so nice to click on
post and just see what people have to
say and I almost wish like you had that
same feeling when you read the comments
a YouTube video instead it's like it's
so many people just copy and pasting so
many Bots that just grab the top comment
from your previous video and paste it
over so top comments on every videos are
the same and the things that break
through that are just scammers trying to
get you to give them a thousand dollars
for a free uh you know fake ad that
comment section is one of the most
Lively on the internet so be amazing if
YouTube invested in creating an actual
Community like where people could do
high effort comments and be rewarded for
it like on Reddit yeah like actually
right out along that would make me so
happy because like when I upload a video
I usually go to Twitter to see feedback
like I read my comments and I'll flip
through newest but it's just I feel like
to read it and Twitter just give me so
much better filtered feedback especially
now that with Twitter blue because
people pay eight dollars a month
um any I've noticed like any tweets I
get from verified users now they're
usually not just garbage troll takes
like these are people paying eight
dollars a month like they're usually
relatively sensible and so it's been
pretty nice like after I upload my video
just go on the verified tab on Twitter
and just see what people have to say and
yeah anyways I live for the day that
YouTube's like that uh what do you think
about Twitter what do you think about
all the
fun activity happening recently since uh
Elon yeah bought Twitter
I think you should make me CEO like I
tweeted
well I should I should say sort of we
had with just like a couple hours ago
had a conversation with Elon and uh you
guys had an exchange of some excellent
ideas so yeah I I legitimately think
obviously you're exceptionally busy but
I legitimately think it would be awesome
if you somehow participate in the future
of Twitter yeah it would be fun because
there's so much possibility of different
ideas first in the sort of the uh the
content like dissemination hosting and
all the different recommendations like
the search and Discovery all the things
that YouTube does well I think the most
exciting thing is he's you know willing
to move fast and so I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting things
that come out of it because he's just
moving quick and a lot of these more
mature platforms just take years to do
the simplest stuff and they're very
bureaucratic and
um so it's gonna I mean it'll be
interesting to see which way it goes
when you just kind of take a move quick
break things whatever type approach to
social media I'm actually pretty curious
to see what Futures he rolls out so what
will be your first uh act as Twitter CEO
I can't spoil it okay I gotta get hired
what do you think about video on the
platform I mean yeah do you think that's
an interesting or is it like messing
with the the medium the nature of the
platform I think Twitter will always be
closer to tick tock than it is to
YouTube but I gotta at least in this
current form I I don't I don't see 20
minute one hour long videos or whatever
you know even 15 minute videos being
watched over there I see it more as like
the short and snappy stuff closer to
tick tock but at the same time Twitter
is a really good comment section for the
internet I mean it's almost weird why
like why doesn't Twitter allow you to
embed YouTube videos like why why does
that you should just ask Elon that like
I don't know if that's a YouTube thing
but when uh YouTuber posts the video why
do they have to link to YouTube why
can't they just embed it on Twitter and
just play it there I mean wouldn't that
just solve a lot of problems yeah but
then the two companies that have to
agree to integrate each other's content
I don't know but it seems like a win-win
I mean well it's more of a win for
Twitter because then people don't have
to leave the platform I mean that would
be the the easiest but who gets like
when you watch the ads on a YouTube
video that's embedded in Twitter who
gets the money it would still be YouTube
but at least then right now people just
post a link and it takes you off Twitter
and it just kills your session time on
Twitter that's really interesting but
that yeah because the Twitter whatever
the the Dynamics of the comments
especially once the spam Bots are taken
care of Twitter just works it's really
so Reddit is a nice comment section for
the Internet it's like slower Pace more
deliberate like a higher effort
Twitter's like this High paced like
ephemeral kind of stream but there's the
vote the upvoting the downvoting works
much better because you can do
retweeting right because the social
network is much stronger than it is on
YouTube like the interconnectivity yeah
on Reddit you're gonna get the the top
replies are going to be the most refined
ones whereas Twitter stuff floats to the
top that's not super refined but like
you're saying it's more off the cuff
stream of Consciousness which a lot of
people prefer gets a little more
personal
how do you think Twitter compares to
YouTube in terms of how you see its
future unroll in 2023. I mean I think
YouTube's gonna be YouTube and not much
is really going to change but it's going
to keep growing just because you know
that's just what it does and because
it's owned by Google
um but Twitter I don't know I mean it's
one of those things like you you can't
predict if I you know a year from now an
economy is going to be in a recession or
booming and I think Twitter's kind of
the same thing one thing for certain a
lot of things are going to be rolled out
but who knows honestly you responded to
Elon saying Twitter's unlikely to be
able to pay creators more money than
YouTube
um what do you think that is well yeah
because I I think the tweet I responded
to is one where he was saying
um that they you know users will jump
over if Twitter could potentially pay
more uh than other platforms and I was
just saying obviously because Google has
Google AdWords and I mean that's
Google's whole thing it's putting ads on
stuff they've been doing it better than
anywhere else in the world for a very
long time it's very unlikely in the next
few years that Twitter is going to
magically or any platform you know give
a Creator the ability to make higher
cpms than on YouTube uh it's it's kind
of crazy like some creators in in
December you know Q4 because ad rates
are higher because of Christmas and
everything some creators literally make
like 30 40 per thousand views that's
after YouTube's cut like it's almost
like hard to think about like how high
the RPMs get and even then once you pull
out a financing cars the highest CFM
niches and you move into just normal
stuff it's still just crazy the sheer
volume of creators and the fact that all
of them get these multi-dollar cpms at
Scales it's pretty beautiful so you do
I don't know what you would call them
but like integrated ads in your videos
and you do I would say masterfully it's
like part of the video you're talking
about brand deals brand deals is that
what you would call that yep so it's a
brand deal it's part of the video
it's still really exciting to watch and
yet there's a plug for the brand in
general just brand deals since you
brought it up uh integrating them well I
think that's something a lot of creators
don't do like they'll just do a brand
deal out of the blue they'll just be
filming a video and then around the
three minute Mark just start talking
about a random company yeah and you I
feel like if you don't want viewers to
click away and you want people to not
get pissed off and call you to sell out
you got to find a way to integrate in
the content and ideally use the money in
the video to make it better like is the
easiest thing you do when you do a brand
deal is just tell people how you're
using money from the brand deal to make
your content better and if you do that
like no one cares now they're supporting
you for it and you go from being a
sellout to like oh I'm doing this to
make better videos for you guys you know
I don't know if you can share but with
those Brands when you have discussions
with them are they strict about how long
you need to be talking about it or is it
more about their leaving control to you
about the artistic element of it the
problem is the the ones who don't give
us the artistic element we just don't
really work with anymore
because it's just you know we get 100
million views of video now and I can
confidently say I know how to entertain
them and convert them better than these
random Brands so uh yeah if they don't
give us that freedom I just won't work
with them so you have that leverage but
for smaller creators it's a lot harder
yeah and they're they're gonna just say
45 seconds here's what you say take it
or leave it and it's like pretty brutal
because I think just in general
if Brands were more accommodating to let
creators tell their story onto Brandon
talk about the brand in a way that felt
a little more natural I I think it'd be
less cringe it people would be less
likely to go and you know tough times
tap Skip and uh obviously it would
convert better but they're just so
afraid and they want this standardized
thing say these words and 45 seconds
right here at this three minute Mark
yeah I often think about how to resist
that you just don't do them though right
not on YouTube right I do an audio I do
ads in the very beginning and I say you
can skip them if you want
um but Brandon loves that I don't like
the point is they
so the funny thing about podcasts is
different than YouTube videos podcast
people actually do listen to ads a lot
because they it's slower paced and they
like the the Creator voice like talking
about the thing
um but in general I just don't believe
you should be talking about a thing for
a minute exactly and that's going to be
effective I want to see the data for
that I think what's much more fact it
was the way you do ads which is like
integrate into the content like put a
lot of effort into making a part of that
like doing the brand deals and
I just it's difficult
to have that conversation it's like a
very
strenuous conversation you have to have
with with Brands you have to each one at
a time and I just wish there was more of
a culture to say like the quality of the
ad read matters a lot more than the uh
like the silly parameters like the
timing of it like how long it is the
placement of it all that kind of stuff
what percentage of your viewers do you
think have seen one of my videos before
what percentage of the viewers on
YouTube right yeah that's your viewers
of the viewers on YouTube though yes
okay sure or all of them it's just
interesting because you're you're
speaking very specifically like about my
brand deal process and so in my head I'm
like I wonder what percentage of these
people even have any idea what he's
talking about that's interesting I love
the thinking about numbers the whole
time we're having this conversation it's
all I could think about is like God damn
it he's there's probably like 50 of
these people have no [ __ ] clue what
he's saying and we're about to torture
him for five minutes yeah yeah probably
but that's something I can't turn off in
my brain less than 50 is that a good
thing or a bad thing is that exciting to
you that that there's like 50 of people
don't I've not watched the Mr Beast
video isn't that an opportunity like
yeah I guess there's an opportunity to
grow I don't know honestly I was just
kind of excited to hang out with you
yeah yeah me too I mean who cares yeah
so it's kind of like having a buddy to
go along the journey as I'm just kind of
eating [ __ ] and doing my normal ride it
was like kind of fun and also you just
say really wise stuff constantly okay so
honestly no I never even put any thought
into like that demographics of what I
could gain it's just interesting because
like my retention brain when you talk
about something I'm instantly like hmm
what value are they gonna get how many
of them are going to be interested what
percentage of people do I think we'll
lose and I'm like running all those
calculations in the background and that
whole conversation like the law is
anyway it's just something I can't turn
off my like Bells were like this is bad
what are the different strategies for
high retention for your videos in
general it's like how do you cook good
food you know what I mean that's like
the same kind of question I see so
there's so many different ways that you
so it boils down to I mean
uh do you think it's at the level of a
story or do you think like literally
watching five seconds at a time am I
gonna tune out here am I gonna tune out
here am I going to tune out here that's
all of it you need the overarching
narrative and then you also need the
micro where every second you know needs
to be entertaining and you basically
what's interesting is the longer people
watch something the more likely they are
to keep watching so you don't have to
try as hard in the hypothetically back
half of a video as you do in the front
like even right now we're so deep into
this where a lot of people listening are
probably just going to keep listening
relatively close to the endless we just
have a really boring part of this
conversation because they're just
they're saying it they're they're
immersed
um and so a big like to really boil it
down to a simple level you just want to
get people where they're immersed in the
content and then just kind of hold them
there we had this discussion offline and
by the way I should mention that this is
like late at night it is what times it's
uh nine o'clock and I uh I only slept
one hour last night because I'm an idiot
and I flew to the wrong location well
here we're like hey
book your hotel on a flight he's like no
I got it we're like you sure we can just
do it we always do this he's like no I
got it I got it he's gonna have to rub
it in I know and then today I come to
find out he flew to the wrong airport
the airport with the uh our city with a
similar name to ours the same name same
name in a different state
and I was like that's why you should let
us book it and so he saw one hour of
sleep and he's literally been dying all
day before this podcast he downed like
two things of coffee we've been going
all day hard uh yeah I've been uh got to
interact with you I should say that this
gave me an opportunity to I gotta uh
ride from a stranger and it was an
incredible person
that got to interact with them so it's
like there's so many kind people around
here just like this kind of Southern
energy and then I got to go to a diner
because I could you know there's only
one hour between me arriving and having
to fly out so I went to a diner there's
a really kind waitress that called me uh
honey so that's a beautiful moment you
know I was so confused you tweeted about
that and like Steel's like like my
assistant uh Lex isn't here yet and I
saw your Tweet and I was like he's here
he was like no he's still flying I was
like four like an hour ago he just
tweeted about a nice Diner yeah it was a
diner it was a diner in a different
state and then you had to fly over here
yeah that was and then I called you you
didn't answer I was like
something's not had enough yeah I feel
like it's such an idiot because um
apparently the world uh has cities like
Springfield right like there's like
every single state has a Springfield oh
really but I think so I think that's
whatever that's like a Simpsons joke
right that like it's uh the the city and
and The Simpsons of Springfield and I
think every single state or most of them
have a Springfield and the same is true
for like uh Georgetown I think the most
part I forget what the most popular one
was but there's like a list of these
people get when they run out of ideas
they just keep us if they're your
Achilles heel anyway I got to I got to
meet a bunch of people from uh from your
team it's just an incredible human being
so let me just ask on that topic how do
you hire a great team like what have you
learned about hiring for
um everything for it for the main
channel that you do uh for the the react
again uh the the gaming channel to uh Mr
Beast Burger to uh feastables all that
the big thing is especially in this
content creation because it's not like
anything that's done on Netflix or or
different uh content medians I I really
need people who are coachable and like
really see the value in what I care
about because it's a very specific way
of going about things and it's a like a
thing there's no one like Plug and Play
like if Netflix wanted to hire someone
to do a documentary there's probably
tens of thousands of people you could
hire that have worked on documentaries
before but if you want to hire someone
to make super viral YouTube videos you
know like we do there's just no one you
you can really pull from like sometimes
I'll hire people from uh game shows
right they have all these preconceived
notions about pacing and how a video
should be and you have to spend like the
first year like breaking all these
habits and you know and they think
they're better than you like a lot of
people in traditional think they're
better and they think their way is
better than what we do and so for me
it's almost easier to hire people that
are just hard workers that are obsessed
and really coachable and just train them
how to like be good at content creation
production than to hire someone from
like traditional which is the only way
to really do it because there's not that
many YouTube channels that have scaled
up so it's not like there's a huge
talent pool of people who've worked on
YouTube channels
um so it's easier just to train someone
than just pull them from traditional
because traditional people just I don't
know they have all these opinions and
things and they just think our way of
going about things is dumb yeah so you
want people who have the humility to
have a beginner's mind even if they have
experience see the value like actually
you'll still get it it's so crazy like
especially some of my other friends that
are Skilling up their YouTube channels
there's people that will come on and
you'll ask them like what do you want to
be doing in five years and instead of
saying oh I want to be working on this
channel they'll be like oh I hope to be
workout movies or this and they see like
working on a YouTube channels the launch
pad to go into traditional and it's like
no like you just don't get it this is
the future is the end goal this is your
career
um and so I'm just so tired of having
those kinds of conversations like I feel
like people really should be coming
around are there like recurring
interview questions that you ask is
there is there ways to get yeah the
biggest thing is like what do you want
to be doing in 10 years and their answer
isn't you know making content on YouTube
or you know if their answer is anything
like movies or traditional stuff like
that it's like just a hell no like it
just won't even remotely work oh so you
really want people to believe in the
vision of YouTube yeah I mean ideally
it's like oh working here you know what
I mean so it's less about the medium and
more about just being on a great team
that's doing epic stuff yeah well and
yeah the media as well because those
it's just it's hard to
put into words but there's it's just two
completely different ways of going about
things you know like our videos aren't
scripted and you know it's a lot more
Run and Gun and when we if we
hypothetically blow up a giant car or
whatever like you only have one take you
know I mean so
um and it's not scripted and so you have
to over film overshoot things over
compensate for like the dumb way of
going about it a lot of traditional
people would be like well just plan what
you're gonna say and just playing the
angles you can cut the cameras in half
you can save 50 Grand here you can save
you know 75 000 editing this and that
and it's like yeah but that's not
authentic like that's you know but you
you get it it's it's almost so obvious
that it hurts to have to like constantly
have these conversations but so where we
live in but there's also detail like
there's a taste like I've watched a
bunch of videos with you and it's clear
to you that you've gotten really good
I don't know what the right word is
style or taste to be able to know what's
good and not in terms of retention in
terms of yeah just stylistically
visually I don't have to think I can
just watch a video and it just it just
screams in my head like this is what
this is what should change based on the
you know million videos I've watched and
all these viral videos are consumed like
this is blah blah what's optimal and
things like that it's almost like your
brain's like a
you know like a neural net like if you
consume enough viral videos and enough
good content that you just kind of start
to like train your brain to like see it
and see these patterns that happen in
all these viral videos and so that
anytime I watch a video or a movie or
anything I just can't stop thinking
about what is optimal and so it's like
it gives me a headache sometimes when I
watch something too slow or I don't
think it's optimal obviously my taste
isn't the end-all feel
um but that's something that kind of
torments me if that makes any sense
oh you can't enjoy a slow moving no I
can't movie and and that's not to say
there's attention on The Godfather is
horrible yeah no exactly I've tried to
watch that movie like three times but
and that's not to say slow movies are
bad like there's an audience for it it's
just obviously not what I've trained my
brain to like and and social media and
YouTube right now like that's just not
the meta and in general like you said in
neural network you're training your
brain
in part on actual data
right so you're actually it's data
driven so you're looking at like in
terms of thumbnails and titles and
different aspects of the first five ten
seconds and then throw out the video the
retention all that you're looking at all
that
uh for your own videos to understand how
to do it better so that's where the
neural network is training yeah
basically there are ways you can kind of
see like the most view videos on YouTube
every day and stuff like that and I just
kind of consume those every single day
and I've been doing that for way too
many years and then you just start to
notice patterns like the thumbnails on
the most view videos or videos that go
super viral tend to be clear tend to not
have much clutter tend to be pretty
simple titles tend to be less than 50
characters intros tend to be this
stories tend to be this and you just
kind of like after you see those
thousands and then tens of thousands of
time it just starts to click in your
head like this is what it looks like you
know so how are you able to transfer
that taste that you've developed to the
team so for like because you said like
broad things but I'm sure there's a
million detailed things like what Zoom
to use on the face to use in the
thumbnail right like the answer is
whatever makes the best video because
the problem is the more
which I have so many friends who are
like this they'll make like checklists
for their editor or something like you
know uh this be in this beat and you
need to have like a three part Arc and
then this but the the problem is that's
how you the the more constraints you put
on the team the more repetitive and less
Innovation you get and the more like you
know after 10 videos people are gonna be
like all right I've already seen this so
to me and I'm 24 and you know I'm
probably my mindset will change over the
next 10 years I just haven't been in
this industry too long but the only way
to like really make Innovative content
and keep things fresh is to not put
constraints on or put as little as
possible and so that's why I'm very
hesitant on all that stuff because the
more I say the more they're gonna be
like oh then that's what we do and then
you know I'll say one time like oh you
know ideally there's a cut every three
seconds and the next thing you know
every video there's like cut every three
seconds or whatever so it's it's hard
because I try to give uh as little
train not training but as little uh
facts or as possible and more just make
suggestions if that makes any you mean
publicly or to your team to my team yeah
what's so we talked about sort of uh
teaching your voice or your style
whatever we want to call it to other
people on the team so they can be kind
of a Mr Beast replacement
so what's the process of teaching that
so you don't wanna no you're more
talking about like uh what I would call
almost like cloning right like like
Tyler and other things like that yeah so
when we were hanging out today I was
showing him how we have multiple people
and they come it's it's almost like
talking to the cameras yeah it turns
slowly to the camera I was like anyways
have it is it weird to you to not be
looking at the camera this whole
interview I constantly have been turning
towards the camera like yeah I'm talking
to him yes it's a habit uh because my
whole life I've just been talking to a
camera who are you thinking about when
you're looking at the camera do you like
imagine somebody I'm fully thinking
about the person just sitting watching
it and I almost it's weird but I'm
looking at the camera I don't see a
camera I'm like in a haze picturing what
the viewer is seeing when they watch it
yeah that makes sense and that's where
I'll be saying things and or doing
something and then like when I'm
watching I'm like that's not what I want
and then I'll freeze up it's very weird
when I'm filming and then for people who
haven't worked with me too much they'll
think like I don't know it's very weird
like the how I go about it because I'll
just be doing whatever like lighting a
firework all right this is a thousand
dollar firework I'll go to lighting and
I'll like freeze because in my head I'm
like this I don't know I don't like how
that float or how that shot looked
because I it's weird I can perfectly
picture what I'm filming by just looking
at the camera and then putting myself
through the lens of the camera while
making content and I can do it at the
same time so you're like real time
editing in my video yeah that's
something that didn't at the start come
natural to me but in the last probably
like five years it's happened and so I
would say it's one of my greatest
strengths but I don't know how I
developed it but anytime I'm filming
anything like it's almost like the like
right side of my brain I just can just
look at it and I see exactly what I'm
filming and I can just picture it well
there's probably recording the video
being the talent for the video and then
watching the editing and like analyzing
you careful and do that over and over
again you'll do that over and over you
ten thousand times yeah you do the
editing more than the being in front of
the camera so like you
you start to see yourself from that
third person perspective exactly then
maybe that actually helps with the
nerves of it too like you see it as
creating a video versus performing uh
right yeah yeah I think so you know I
it's weird I've never
been nervous talking to a camera it's
it's harder for me to talk to a person
that doesn't talk to a camera which I
feel like a lot of people say that
though that are whatever make content
right interesting I've heard that so
many times
or maybe not maybe I'm just awkward
enough maybe they're practiced I to me
it's I mean both are terrifying but
being in front of the camera by yourself
is so much easier really yeah so much
easier I preferred a million times over
[Applause]
but that's my whole life you know so
it's just that's why it's interesting
like you've spent more of your time
talking to people yeah it comes natural
and I talk to
a piece of plastic oh yeah I guess
you're talking to a person too they're
just then on the other side of the
camera yeah there's just a pixel on the
screen so so cloning how do you how do
you achieve this oh yeah that's right
that's all right so I was showing him
that I have a lot of people in the
company who are able to think like me
and uh basically make decisions like I
would make if I was like if you were
asked hey in this video should we climb
a mountain or should we dig a hole right
and like you know they would pick the
same answer I'd pick 90 plus percent of
the times and so one example is Tyler
who I was showing you and he was
pitching some content and you could see
it like this he was on point and uh
basically for just four or five years we
just spent an absurd amount of time
together and worked on every single
video together and we worked uh side by
side and same thing with uh my CEO James
he literally lived with me for a couple
years I'm a big fan of just like finding
people who are super obsessed and all in
and a players that you know they really
just want to be great and then just
dumping everything
and like you were saying because I'd
love to find that uh and develop that
you're saying you're basically for a
long time just said everything you were
thinking to them exactly like uh James
the the guy who's basically my right
handman right now
um for two years he lived with me and we
probably talk on average of those two
years seven hours a day I mean anytime I
had a phone call I'd throw it on speaker
and I'd let him listen anything I was
reading any content I was consuming like
really just training his brain to think
like me so that way
um he could just do things without my
input without me having to constantly
watch over him or give him advice and
and that's where we've gotten like so
for the first six months he didn't do
anything he just studied me and studied
everything I cared about and how I spoke
and blah blah and then the next six
months he started taking on some
responsibilities and now he can just run
the company and you know I don't ever
really have to check in on him like I
most the decisions he makes are exactly
what I would do
um and so I I call that cloning I don't
know what other people would but it's
just like finding people that are really
obsessed and they just kind of really
want it and just being like giving them
an Avenue to like get it if that makes
any sense another way to see it is
you're converging towards a common
vision and that makes like brainstorming
much more productive yeah it just makes
it where I don't have to be so involved
in everything because I just have these
people I know will think like I will uh
at least relatively close to it so I can
kind of almost be in multiple places at
once per se and so these things that you
know I still approve every idea we film
and you know everything before we film
it all the creative I approve it but I
don't have to like be in the weeds and
nuances and do all this minor stuff I
can just let them handle it I can just
do the more macro things I got a chance
to sit in to a lengthy brainstorming
session with Tyler and others that was
really cool
can you talk about the process of that
of uh
people pitching ideas
and you pitching Alternatives or
shutting down ideas and it's just going
like plowing through ideas very good I
mean you kind of just describe exactly
what we did yeah I mean but the ideas
are really really good it's just tossing
out
like different categories of ideas and
then also fine-tuning them to see like
you know I changed like thinking about
the titles and the stuff I worked so
well off of inspiration it's like that's
a something
like give give me anywhere I don't know
space yeah like I went to space you know
what happens if you love a nuke in space
or I went to the moon I went to Mars
right because you said that one word it
was able to inspire me to come up with
four ideas and so that's just it's for
me
if you the way to get 100 million views
on videos you need something original
creative something people really need to
see ideally never been done before all
these like things and so you need like
if you want to consistently go
supervisor you need just a constant
stream of ideas and the only way I've
really found that I can consistently
come up with 100 million view videos is
to intake inspiration and then see what
my brain outputs and so that's kind of
at its core Foundation what I'm doing
there is just like in taking a lot of
random inspiration to see what spawns in
my mind so I can output it but the
neural network of your brain is
generating
the video the title the thumbnail all
that jointly exactly and that only comes
because I spent 10 years of my life just
obsessively studying all that stuff
because you I mean it seems like you
would literally potentially shut down a
video just because you can't come up
with a good title yeah or a thumbnail
yeah I mean that's what happened to 70
of those in that pitch session I was
just like oh what was one of them genius
versus 100 people or yeah like maybe
average intelligence versus genius yeah
I was like what the heck is the
thumbnail even if the title was good
yeah yeah I mean there's so many but
yeah people don't click they don't watch
that's so interesting but you developed
over time the ability to kind of give it
what what makes for a good title short
not just short it's also I mean
if someone reads it are they like do
they have to watch it is it just so
intrinsically interesting that it's just
gonna [ __ ] with them if they don't click
on it you know what I mean so it doesn't
have to be short but it has to be
like you almost want to have a retention
to word by word reading ideally it's a
title also that
um you know because the titles don't
live in a vacuum right so it has to lead
into the content so ideally the title
represents content that you would want
to watch for 20 minutes so if it's a 20
minute video and the title is I stepped
on a bug it's not gonna because it's all
of it combined it's the click-through
rate is going to be much lower and then
if it was like a five second video
people might click it so you gotta like
even nuances of the length of the video
based against the title will affect
whether people want to click it because
sometimes they just all add up I mean
it's that yes ideally you want it below
50 characters because above 50
characters on certain devices you run
the chance of it going dot dot dot so
like I took a light pole and I saw how
many dollar bills I could stack on top
and they would just go dot dot because
it's too long and it can't finish it and
that's the worst thing because then
people don't even know what they're
clicking on and so it's going to do even
worse
um short simple ideally and just so
freaking interesting they have to click
and it is a good segue into the content
and represents the length of the content
and there's probably stuff it's hard to
kind of convert into words for you like
I stepped on a bug versus stepping in a
bug versus Mr B stepped on the bus well
I mean that bug stepping that up so it's
like yes the more extreme the opinion
typically the higher the click-through
rate if you can like uh
pay it off in the content then it just
supercharges it so like oh so you have a
kind of estimate of the experience this
water right if you're like
Fiji Water sucks yeah that would do fine
but if you said Fiji Water is the worst
water bottle or the worst water I've
ever Drank In My Life yeah way more
extreme opinion would do way better but
you have to deliver yeah but then you
have to deliver because the more extreme
you are the more extreme you have to be
in the video yeah that's almost
inspiration for you to step up yeah but
you can you can be more extreme in a
positive way a lot of people it's easier
though
pause it
uh negative clickbait is much easier
than positive Cliff it just is it's so
much easier to get Negative clicks and
so a lot of people are just in my
opinion you know a little bit lazier and
they just take the route like oh well
this one gets the same amount of clicks
and it's easier less effort the positive
one is doing a large number of numbers
of something like I I spent this number
of hours doing this or whatever if you
just wanted to help people or right it's
just harder to get 10 million views on a
video helping people than it is to get
10 million views on a video tearing down
a celebrity you know what I mean or
whatever negative video you want to
insert there well that said most of your
videos are pretty positive so what's but
not a lot of people do those kinds of
videos because they're hard yeah they're
hard some of that is giving away money
right yeah um what's the secret to that
what's how do you do do that right yeah
like give away money or in a video that
made to make it compelling
um is it so there's a number that is
better than another number right the
higher number is always better than the
other number yeah for the most part and
you know it's interesting like some
videos will give away a million dollars
some videos will give away half a
million there's not really I guess so
I'm retracting what I just said I was
more joking with that but there's no
difference whether I put 500k or a
million it's probably not even really a
difference between 100K a million I
haven't really looked into it like some
of our mostly videos are not us giving
away a million dollars and sometimes the
million dollar videos just don't do as
well as the other ones so there there's
a certain point where a dollar amount is
just a large dollar amount to an average
human and so I think that point is 100k
like anything above 100K the average
human's just like that's a lot of money
you know it doesn't it doesn't 100K a
million like it doesn't really move the
needle if that makes sense which that's
a very nuanced piece of information that
applies to very few people but yeah well
no I think it applies it's fascinating
it's fascinating human our relationship
with money is fascinating like why is it
so exciting to get
I mean I you know the times I found like
20 bucks in the ground
are like incredible really I don't know
why right why why are you so happy like
what exactly is so joyful about that I
mean it depends where you are in life
what the situation is yeah I don't know
there's also a gamified aspect to it
it's exciting yes no I get it like why
people want to see people win money it's
just interesting that past 100 Grand
it's it doesn't really seem to make a
difference like it's the same basically
so you found that to be true with all
the money you've given away that I just
didn't click through it like obviously
in terms of someone receiving it yeah a
million dollars changes their life
drastically more
like that's the difference like oh you
if you wanted to you could really quit
your job as opposed to 100K is like not
really you probably do like a scientific
study like a formula giving away money
to click-through rate yeah there could
be some kind of digestion return it
definitely the the returns level off
dramatically after 100K that's basically
the premise what about ten thousand uh
no there's ten a hundred thousand is
that it's funny because this is such a
small Niche thing but yeah 100 000 does
it from what I see in our videos get
more clicks than ten thousand but the
difference between a hundred thousand
million is just so little I just I think
big number big number to a lot of people
past that point yeah so for 100 000 you
can like give an average salary you
could probably live for a year given
give them a day out average salaries in
America so that's like a big that feels
yeah I think it's also just more when
they read the title it's just like it's
a lot of zeros [ __ ] loads of zeros Okay
click yeah
oh man that's fascinating so on the
thumbnail side again that's going to be
much harder to say probably
um but you know offline you know I got a
chance to look at a bunch of thumbnails
and it's fascinating which ones do well
and which ones don't is there something
you could say about what are the
elements of a thumbnail that work well
is this also deeply well that's where
yeah it's the same thing like how do you
cook good food but um it's easier if you
pull up a thumbnail I could be like
that's why that's good that's why that's
bad that's uh like an example would be
like one of my friends I was he just
uploaded a video recently and I called
him I was like what is this because he's
a very very smart guy and then the
thumbnail he's he's getting chased by
cops but the cops are wearing yellow
vests so they didn't look at cops I was
like whoa why are the cops in your
thumbnail wearing yellow vests it's like
that makes it so much more boring and he
was like carrying a flag but the poll
and the color of the flag were the same
color so it's like it's a lot harder to
see the flag I was like also you're
wearing like a shirt with like five
different colors like so it's like it's
hard to tell what even what your outline
is and then in the background there were
cars and I was like oh if you have cops
chasing you why not make the cars cop
cars and you know and it's like because
in my head I'm like dang if he just did
those like four or five things the video
probably got like seven next the views
how much iteration because I also got a
chance to see the number of iterations
you do on a on just it's a problem now
it's an addiction is it so you kind of
there's a lot of the versions were
really good yeah how do you know when to
like I love how you when we pulled up
that uh the burger one and we were
flipping through them you're like that's
really good I was like oh that's version
like one of like a thousand but even the
sketch the idea was good like already
even the original idea is strong yeah so
we one of our coming up videos we made
the world's largest plant-based burger
and the thumbnail we were thinking is
like me standing beside the bird because
it's six feet tall that's that's what
he's talking about so like just picture
a giant six foot tall burger super wide
thousands of pounds and then I'm beside
it and then it's like eating the world's
largest burger like you that's just
something you have to click like so you
were saying like how would you describe
a good thumbnail like that you know what
I mean like but I think you said the one
I noticed first that was good where you
were very small in it relative to the
and you didn't like that one I needed to
come forward a little bit and also the
photo we took was uh just my upper body
yeah so they photo manipulating created
my legs Photoshop and that's why I said
I didn't like it because my right leg
was a little like off it was like bent
the wrong way
does the physics and thumbnail have to
even make sense I mean you can just like
exaggerate the head size and all that
kind of yeah 100 yeah things don't have
to be relative yeah you can have a car
in the background be three times the
size yeah because yeah every one of my
thumbnails my face is in the you know
left side very big so brand recognition
so just people know oh especially
because now that a lot of people copy
our videos it's just nice to like you
know everyone else might make thumbnails
like this but this is mine and obviously
we usually over deliver and do bigger
stuff would you recommend to other
creators that wanna that wanna make it
big to and they see Mr Beast and they
look up to you to copy some elements of
you or to really try to be unique unique
100 unique you're not the next Mr Beast
quote feels weird saying that third
person but whatever is not gonna do what
I'm doing better they're gonna just
invent their own lane like you're just
not going to do what I do better than me
you know I have so many I literally have
the best people in the world working
here and I I reinvest everything I make
even to this day you know what I mean
like it's absurd the amount of money I
spent on content and I don't care I'll
just stop sleeping and I'll just film
every other day like you're just not
gonna beat me at my own game and that's
fine you shouldn't like I didn't get
where I am by just beating someone else
out there again I just found my own lane
and innovated and adapted and so yeah
there's a lot of people that do copy me
and it's fine whatever do it but just
know you're not gonna get to where I am
doing that
um and so I'd advise you don't you give
away a lot of the secrets basically
everything yeah about how you operate is
there uh I don't hold anything back go
for it you know how do you think about
that because that's also that's pretty
rare I think and this is a definitely
not uh most people in my stance I don't
think would take this or my position
would take this stance but I see every
other YouTuber or so person on social
media even because we're also focused
super heavily on YouTube but last year
we're also the most followed Tick Tock
Creator in the world as well I actually
remember most subscribed to YouTube
channel world and the most followed Tick
Tock account in the world
um but uh in general I just see everyone
else as uh collaborators not competitors
I I don't think giving advice and
helping other creators do well in any
way harms me and I think it only brings
more value to my life how is it jumping
on Tick Tock and trying to understand
that platform from scratch yeah so from
being a successful YouTuber to
understand a totally different algorithm
fundamentally different algorithm it's
interesting well not even just the
algorithm just the content like I'm
going from basically 15 minute short
films to one sub one minute vertical
content at least a whole different just
ballpark
um and so the first little while is
doing Tick Tock it was just kind of
figuring out how what does Mr Beast look
like in this short form content but
recently we've really started to catch
our stride and come up with some
original Concepts and figure out how to
innovate over there just like we did on
YouTube because I don't want it I didn't
want it to just be shitty YouTube videos
yeah you know and so like an example is
um we played the rock for 100k and rock
paper scissors and the loser had to
donate 100K to charity we did um we went
to random people on a campus and we
offered them so I said I'll give you a
hundred dollars if you fly to Paris to
give me a baguette and then they said no
and I was like I'll give you 300 if a
lot of hairs and give me a big hat and I
was expecting this person to say no and
it go up to like 10 grand he's like yes
and so he flew to Paris got a baguette
and brought it back and gave it to me
and that across everything got like 450
million views and because it's just
really cool just to see this random guy
get on a plane spend a day in Paris and
we cut it up real nicely and bring it
back and so we're starting to find just
tons of original content over there but
it seems like an epic video to make for
one minute exactly no one on short forms
doing it that's the thing it's like okay
it's just so funny because like tick
tock's been big for a while now years
and then um you know as as we started to
really figure out things on the YouTube
channel and get it cranking where I have
some free time we we set our sights on
Tick Tock and like okay what are people
not doing how do we make it better put
in more effort make it good and we did
the same thing we did at YouTube just
different over on Tick Tock and it
worked and now we're the fastest growing
or most followed Tick Tock account in
2022 and it's just funny that no one
else did that and you're not afraid to
do epic stuff which also during the
brainstorming some of the ideas you're
like that's better as a short that's
crazy yeah can you remember one because
I remember I said that a bunch but I
can't think of what all I remember is
that they were like epic videos
like really you're going to do that for
a one minute video yeah that's crazy so
like are you posting similar content to
a YouTube short as a tick tock yeah
those would just double up it's just
hard you know what's actually pretty
fascinating in people who do social
media listening to this will probably
find this pretty interesting because the
picture of like the content creation
meta three years ago versus now where
you can make sub one minute vertical
content and it go viral on Tick Tock and
go viral on YouTube shorts go viral on
Instagram reels it goes viral on
Facebook it goes Reddit you know you
swipe through vertical content now and
Twitter when you click on a video and
you flip through it so this is actually
very weird this is the first time in the
history of I guess Western social media
that one form of content could actually
go super viral on every single platform
it's never been like that before so
they're going viral individually they're
not like like something or whatever I
can post something on Tick Tock they'll
get 100 million views and then post it
on shorts and it'll get 200 million
views and then post it on Instagram and
I get 50 million views and then you know
I haven't yet but you know you can then
turn around and tweet it and get tens of
millions of views and you can post it on
Reddit get tons of interviews and and
Facebook and get tens of millions of
views and that that just wasn't a thing
three years ago Twitter didn't have when
because a lot of you probably don't even
know this but when you tap on a video
now and you swipe down it just turns
into Tick Tock that wasn't a thing even
a year ago Reddit that wasn't a thing a
year ago probably two years ago that
wasn't a thing on Instagram three years
ago that wasn't a thing on YouTube right
with YouTube shorts so this is all new
and uh I don't it's weird I haven't
heard a single person talk about it but
this is the first time where content can
actually go viral on every single
platform and you don't have to write or
film a video for Facebook film a 12
minute video for YouTube film a sub 60
second video for tick tock write a tweet
for Twitter and post this on Reddit you
can just do the same thing on every
platform and the fact that your content
has gone viral on multiple platforms
regularly means that
virality is not accidental
sometimes it can be of course but it's
it's just it can be engineered it's yeah
so many people say it's luck and they're
like you're just lucky or this or that
but what are we up to probably like a
thousand videos over 10 million views
like we don't ever have a dud like you
can call it luck but I think it could be
trained I I counsel YouTubers all the
time and show them how to go from
getting a couple million views a month
to 10 million views a month very easily
if I'm even certain ones like
just one of my friends like he was just
really struggling and so I just started
showing him basically everything I know
and just doing like once every week
sometimes once every two weeks calls and
it went from ten thousand dollars a
month on YouTube to over four hundred
thousand just doing these little
counseling calls and so I mean people
can make excuses all they want and say
it's just luck or say you know
um well anyways I don't even want to
quote all the other stuff but it's just
it is it is a teachable skill it's a
learnable skill you can study your way
to consistently make viral videos no
matter how small your channel is even if
you have zero subscribers you could if
if you actually studied hard enough and
like basically if you knew what I knew
and some of these so I don't sound so
arrogant also like some of these other
friends I have that I'd say are the
smartest people in the world when it
comes to content creation online if you
had the knowledge that was in our heads
you could do it very easily I see people
do it all the time
um and what's even more interesting is I
go on podcasts and I say everything I
know and these people are also very open
some of them I know it's all out there
and a lot of people instead of just
studying that and trying to absorb and
apply it in their own way they're just
like no it's just luck you know so you
do lay it all out there but I gotta push
back to one interesting thing I I think
a crucial component of your success is
the idea stage the idea generation the
brainstorm I heard today but getting
really good at generating idea is so
it's not it's not just
the uh the selection of the thumbnail
and the title that creative process it's
also just the the engine of generating
really good ideas of course and getting
that I mean I I would say that is
probably the thing that needs to be
trained the most for most creators right
that they're they just don't put enough
ideas on paper yes but also a lot of
creators also just don't
you know which I didn't either for the
longest time just didn't don't make good
enough content you know content that's
worthy of getting 10 million views in
the idea or the execution of the idea
both I mean like think about how many
people just make videos they film in
under 20 minutes and they don't really
put any effort into it and like you know
it's like my first 500 videos didn't
deserve to get a million views like
there's a reason they did they're
terrible you know but at the time I
thought they did right now I'm in the
mindset of a lot of small YouTubers or I
thought those videos deserved a million
views and I thought the algorithm hated
me but I watched them back now and I can
tell you exactly why the videos was
[ __ ] horrible you know what I mean
well so what was the Breakthrough for
you to start realizing to start having a
self-awareness you know about these
videos aren't good enough you're
probably still going through that you're
probably still growing to see like yeah
every six months you should look back
and hate your videos or at least see
things you could improve and be like oh
I could have done this better that
better if not then you're not learning
quick enough in my opinion at least
where's the source of that learning even
for you now uh just look at it I just
got back from him no I'm I just got back
from a mastermind where I just got like
you know 10 of the smartest people I
knew and we just locked ourselves in a
cabin and taught each other stuff
constantly every day not every day now
probably every other day I go on a walk
and I just call random people I'll just
say teach me something and uh I mean
it's just uh you just have to have a
never-ending thirst for Learning Link
that's very imperative especially if you
want like if you want to get on top and
then stay on top the only way to do it
is just to constantly be learning or
someone who is learning is just gonna
you know have a leg up on you in the
knowledge game and what kind of stuff
are you because you you've talked about
Offline that you just love learning of
all kinds it doesn't matter but in terms
of videos are you studying videos are
you studying recently not as much I'm
more because to get to the videos I want
I have to build this business and scale
up and hire so one of my recent time has
been like my teenage years were spent
studying virality and studying content
creation Now I'm studying how to build a
Content company so I can actually
produce the crazy ideas I want to
produce if that makes any sense so yeah
and that's the business side uh we
talked about hiring do you have trouble
firing people no I'm pretty sure almost
every person yeah actually every person
I've ever heard we just give them
Severance and I like to see it more as
it's no ill well like if there's like if
I fired you if is there's some other job
you want me to help you get i'll DM them
on Twitter like you know if you want to
go work for I don't know insert whatever
MTV give me someone to DM I'll DM like
you know I I try to make it more like a
transition and do whatever we can to
make it as easy as something was just
not working for you because you want
people like you said super passionate
because at the end of the day if you
hold someone that you uh onto someone
that you don't see being here in 10
years you're just doing a disservice
you're just giving them more ingrained
more and rooted and where where they are
um and the sooner you do it and help
them move on to their like new life the
better
given all the wisdom you have now if you
were to give advice to somebody or if
you were to start over again
uh you had no money what would be the
first 10 videos you tried to uh to make
on a new channel I guess that's advice
for a new person and nobody knows you
yeah and nobody knows me yeah like
hypothetically I have a mask on and you
also I guess don't have the wisdom well
if I don't have what I have in my head
then I would say just fail like just a
lot of people get analysis paralysis and
they'll just sit there and they'll plan
their first video for three months and
yeah I'm any of you listening if if you
especially if you have zero videos on
your channel your first video is not
going to give views period it's not your
first ten are not gonna give views I can
very confidently say that so stop
sitting there and thinking for months
and months on end and just get to work
and start uploading like all you need to
do this this applies to people who have
not uploaded videos but have dreams of
being a YouTuber is make 100 videos and
improve something every time do that and
then on your 101st video we'll start
talking like maybe you can get some
views but you know your first hundred
are gonna there are very freak cases
like Liza koshy or Emma Chamberlain who
have really good personalities and it
doesn't take them so as many videos and
it's just like people who are seven foot
five and making an NBA like yes there
are free cases you can find but for the
average person like us you know who
don't have these exceptional
personalities and you know backgrounds
in filmmaking just make 100 videos
improve something each time and then
talk to me on your 101st video well the
improve something his time is the tricky
one how do you improve something each
time the second one just I don't know
put more effort into the script the
third one try to learn a new editing
trick the fourth one try to figure out a
way that you can have better inflections
in your voice the fifth one try to you
know study a new thumbnail tip and
implement it the sixth one try to figure
out a new title there's infinite ways
that's the beauty of content creation
online there's literally infinite ways
from the coloring to the frame rate to
the editing to the filming to the
production to the jokes to the pacing to
every little thing can be improved and
they can never not be improved there's
no there's literally no such thing as a
perfect video
so if you knew everything you know now
but no money step one would I just
brainstorm like okay I don't have money
what are some viral things like I mean
the first thing that comes to my mind is
something as simple as when I count to a
hundred thousand which is what I did do
and I I was poor
um and like that worked but like what's
something like that I could do that
would be even more attention yeah you
were as part of the brainstorm
you would throw out a lot of ideas and
people throw out a bunch of ideas and
one of the questions is is this even
doable right yeah first off come up with
ideas you think would do well and then
ask yourself later if they're doable
yeah because there's there's different
ways you can accomplish something don't
be cynical about the doability of stuff
yeah because there really are so many
different ways you can accomplish a goal
like
um
when we give away an island like we give
our 100 million subscribers Island yeah
you know you can't find private islands
that you know don't look like [ __ ] for
less than 10 million dollars so this
isn't doable right all right the idea
doesn't exist not doable exit off but
then you know you dig into it and you
you know find different Alternatives and
you find okay what if we just buy a two
million dollar Island that sucks and
then spend a million dollars you know
importing some sand let's build a beach
let's import 300 trees let's put a
little bit of canals cut some pass boom
now it's a really nice Island but it's
actually affordable because we don't
have 10 million dollars to spend on
video but we can afford to spend three
and a half and lose whatever a million
dollars on that video so like that's an
example of like yeah if you just went
off the gut test you're like this isn't
doable you know every island is 10
million dollars we're screwed like if we
go cheaper it's just a terrible Island
no and so if you like there are so many
different ways you can achieve what you
want you've really got to push through
notes which not a lot of people do you
have to have like a more of a dominant
personality and just a willingness to
um when people tell you it's not
possible just actually go through all
the variables and eliminate them all
yourself
have a stubbornness
and uh resilience to failure maybe for
what we do and creators online it's very
imperative that you have
that a no isn't a no deal that you
really have to like think and um and
just like we we take a personality test
and like just having a dominant
personality is a better indicator that
when someone tells you oh there's no way
you're going to build a brick wall for
under 100 Grand you know you'll be like
okay and then still go check the next 10
vendors and you know figure it out
yeah uh what advice would you give to an
already established Channel like with
one two three four million subscribers
how to like 10x it like increase it
um without losing maybe yeah that's
where it's very specific like Channel by
Channel you can't give general advice
okay yeah because if I do millions of
creators are gonna see this and then
they're gonna do it and I'm gonna [ __ ]
them over you know oh I see so let's say
I had like two million subscribers on
this podcast yeah like how would you 10x
that without sacrificing what it is 10x
is your stuff does it matter so we
you've talked about with success yeah
it's different for everyone like is
10xing your definition of success no
well then it's gonna right off the bat
it's hard because if you don't give a
[ __ ] about 10x thing it's even harder
for 10x
um he does this because he likes helping
people that's one thing I found
throughout this day every time I talk
data it's so funny with him because it's
like you know you could do this to get
more views and he'll just be like blank
I'll be like that doesn't register
anything he's just like doesn't care
which is it's really I'm really nervous
about that I'm really nervous about the
numbers affecting because it's so fun oh
yeah it's so fun to focus on the numbers
and I'm I'm really worried about that
but at the same time you should be
cognizant of that because you've created
not just some of the most watched videos
but some of the most amazing videos ever
so it's there's a strong correlation
there it's not like you're selling your
soul to make a highly viewed video it's
actually if you look at the metrics
it helps you understand what is
compelling and not and so I feel like I
am
uh
I feel like there's some value to
investigate what work when people tune
on and when not to be more data driven
even on podcasts but I'm really afraid
on the flip side I think part of the
appeal is that you don't care about that
kind of stuff
but there there could be stuff that
doesn't have to do anything with that it
has to do with stylistic choices of
lighting and cameras or maybe with uh
um for example topics yeah you know like
even what you've asked me here is like
different than what most people ask me
yeah so it could be I mean and it'd be
nice to understand that but yeah again
I'm worried about polluting at the end
of the day it's it's this is a true case
of it's your own intuition like you know
your viewers better than anyone else
it's whatever see I'd like to push back
on that I really don't you do who else
name one person who knows your viewers
better than you
uh somebody that looks at numbers of
podcasts no you know your viewers you
know you're the only how many episodes
Have You Done uh 350. exactly but I'm
not paying it you're the only one who's
watched every second of all 350 of them
probably that's just that's just not no
you haven't but the okay well because
you did it so you do know what's in all
of them sure your content is you people
I'm telling you you do and this is just
one of those moments where you're an
intelligent guy and you just have to
trust your like instincts like just
think what is the typical X viewer and
what do they want I don't think like
that my tip but that's all you would
have to do and whatever your gut tells
you that would be the best guess you
don't know what the typical viewer is
though I don't I know because to
investigate that would be very very
difficult and then you have to start
looking at the numbers you have to start
to like consider demographics the only
way I know that anybody even watches it
is because I'll sometimes run into
people like when I run along the river
and they'd be like I love you Lex it's
like okay well that that's that's the
data point and they're like cool people
but you know I don't know any like I
don't have any other
it's difficult man it's difficult to
know
it's difficult to know who listens to
boxes the difficult do you have a sense
of who's I mean like you're so huge that
everybody watches yeah uh but no I still
do I would say if you were to just put a
gun to my head and you're you're like
all right we're gonna pick a random
person that watched your last video and
you have to like roughly guess what they
are and if you're not close we'll kill
you I would say probably like a teenager
that plays video games like some
something like that would be probably
the typical one and then there are
people that are maybe a little bit
younger a lot of people are are older as
well but in a ramble random sample size
yeah it's probably like I'm a male boy
that plays video games like that's the
best way I would describing it but I
don't try to pertain to them I just make
whatever I think is interesting and good
content
um and this is what we were talking
about before even though hypothetically
35 to 40 of my audience is uh women
which is you know less than a majority
if we get 100 million views of video
that's still 30 to 40 million females
that watch every video which is probably
the largest uh you know views per video
for women on the whole platform which
you wouldn't think that you know uh like
I can't think of a single other creator
that gets more women to watch their
videos than that
um and so it's just anything even like
people above the age of 30 even if it's
only like three or four percent that's
still three to four percent of 100
million views there's a lot of people
that age so we we hit a large group of
uh of kind of every demographic if that
makes any sense so what if we look at
other maybe more challenging kinds of
channels or not but if we look at
educational for example like lectures or
if we look yeah educational it could be
short videos like how would you
10x that like uh something on Robotics
and biology on science on engineering on
all of that that's more educational
focused we would honestly just have to
pull the because it's the same way if
you went to Gordon Ramsay you said how
would a new cook cook better you know
it's like even then that's not even
specific you have to go Channel by
Channel you really do or I'm I'm giving
horrible advice because if there was
these just school rules everyone would
do it you know what I mean like if
there's these magical little principles
how quickly when you look at a channel
can you kind of give advice yeah it's
it's like surface love at the start and
then the more if we watch 10 videos I
feel like I'd have a good profile and I
could tell you in my opinion you know
one especially once I look at the
analytics and I get more ingrained in
like okay the typical viewers this
they're from here here's how they're
feeling you know because there are
people who make videos for rednecks and
like the Rednecks Taste of content is
just so much different than obviously
women watching makeup videos which are
so much different than you know teenage
boys watching a Minecraft video they're
just all different so the biggest thing
you have to do is put put your head your
head in the headspace of the viewer and
see the content how they would because
if you just try to only give your taste
which is what a lot of people do and
things from your perspective it's very
biased and it's just not going to work
for everyone and that's actually how you
do more harm than good which is
something I'm very careful of yeah but
at the same time just generating a lot
of ideas I think the first time I've
talked to you was on clubhouse actually
yeah I mentioned something about robots
and like almost immediately went to
generating a bunch of ideas around
audiobooks uh it's just 100 Robots
versus a hundred humans yeah how far can
a robot throw a potato I think your idea
like I think the first idea was because
you just said so many ideas I never even
thought of
but it's it's it shows the value of uh
basically brainstorming with people that
think differently but at the end of the
day my ideas are probably you know might
lean towards some people a little bit
younger than your audience like some of
the stuff yeah but there's still the
ideas like I think the first one you
said because we're talking about uh
quadruped like a robot dogs you said to
replace a biological dog with a robot
dog and see if the owner notices
something you're just quickly
brainstorming different ideas of like
how this was years ago I remember that
yeah which is just I mean it's like oh
yeah I never really thought about that
kind of so it's the basic the tension
between what does it take for a robot
and our AI system to replace the
biological systems that we the
biological creatures that we that we
love in our lives yeah and but like that
was like the um
the pace of idea generation
was the thing that struck me today and
in general it's like that's how you get
at good videos is you keep keep things
it's much easier to make a video around
a good idea obviously than a bad one
you're just setting yourself up for
Success okay so that's for uh 10x thing
already popular
um Channel what's the hardest number you
said uh
the numbers that matters click-through
rate average view duration and and uh
surveys
what's the hardest number to uh optimize
for probably surveys you know do you
have any do you have an insight into the
surveys at all no not really but if you
just click on a bunch of random videos
online you'll eventually get a survey
what's this video transformative
heartwarming inspiring what people rate
does make a difference
um and it's like you can get people to
click a video you can get them to watch
it but you can't really fake whether or
not they're satisfied like they don't
lie the service you know
um you know maybe one person here
they're my troll but once you're
aggregate enough it's a pretty clear
Telltale of the video so either you're
making a great video or you're not
what is it uh minimizing the non
regrettability yeah I think Elon tweeted
that's what he's trying to do on Twitter
Twitter and that's interesting that's
that's basically the survey metric how
happy you are that you've been using the
platform yeah you know untreated we want
to limit the amount of regrettable
minutes people spend on Twitter and uh
the first thing I thought it's like
that's something YouTube already has a
lot like their whole Survey System when
feedback loop how tough is it to take on
YouTube you think
like um for Twitter yeah for Twitter for
anybody else
um I mean it's gonna be basically
impossible I mean YouTube's not going
anywhere and I mean I don't know I don't
I don't think anyone's gonna do what
YouTube does better than them uh at
least not in the next 10 years
you asked on Twitter would you rather
have 10 million dollars or 10 million
subscribers on YouTube uh what would
your own answer be at various stages in
your career if uh if if I had nothing I
would say 10 million dollars so because
with 10 million dollars you can hire
some people and pump out content with
like a million or two get 10 million
subscribers and then keep the other 8
million so that's if you believe in your
ability to grow a channel if you uh well
if you yeah if you don't believe in your
ability to grow Channel then you
shouldn't take the 10 million
subscribers because you're just gonna
kill the channel so the 10 million is
definitely a better question would be
would you rather have a million dollars
or 10 million subscribers that's where
it gets a little tricky because now it's
like hmm you know a million dollars
life-changing amount of money uh but you
know if you Sim I know what you're doing
you probably make a million dollars off
a 10 million subscriber Channel but it
is a little bit a million dollars might
not be enough to to build a strong team
because you don't know how to do it so
you might waste all that money yeah or
they just keep it and retire yeah okay
that's true yeah because 10 million's
just so high it's like just never work
again who cares for the average human
that's so much money it's interesting to
me also do the value of the subscriber
versus the value of the dollar
um I suppose how valuable is a
subscriber for
uh like what percentage of the videos
like how active are the subscribers and
watching the video
um
for you that's hard I don't know I was
actually thinking more about the
subscriber to Dollar like if someone has
10 million subscribers have they made 10
million dollars I don't know why that
that kind of popped in my head it's an
interesting thought
uh do you ever when you analyze uh
videos do you ever analyze videos like
we've talked about offline of other
videos across the YouTube in general
just to understand trying to understand
social behavior all your not all but a
lot of questions are analytics based
yeah yeah it's so because I love it uh I
mean it's just a giant social experiment
right like what people like to watch
what people share yeah it's like a
fascinating so I hate that so like I
said before what percentage of your
audience do you think care about this
kind of stuff like this deeply about
YouTube Analytics I think a large amount
care about
uh curiosity and exploration of
interesting ideas so in that sense yeah
this would this was fitted I love it
this is funny this isn't me like trying
to like I I love you and I actually I
love future Magnus one and I um and even
your Hikaru one was really good a bunch
of other ones but I think we're getting
to the point now where only analytics
junkies would want to keep hearing more
analytics talk and the Normie is
probably like they've had their dose of
YouTube talk for the next three years
maybe I'm wrong hey comment if I'm wrong
I could be I don't know your audience
see this is where you would tell me Shut
up I know my audience you dumbass and I
don't at all I actually I just follow
the threat of curiosity and I think
there's just a lot of curious humans in
the world and and to me it's like
so the question about analytics is the
question of basically stepping away
stepping outside of yourself and
thinking why the hell do I like Tick
Tock so much why do I like Twitter so
much why do I like YouTube so much and
getting even if you're not a Creator
getting an insight into that is really
interesting
it's like what
uh because because all these platforms
are fundamentally changing the nature of
content people are reading books less
they're probably going to be watching
movies less and less they're probably
going to be watching Netflix less and
less
do you ever think about the the sort of
the darker side of YouTube and
um with Shadow Banning and censorship
and all that kind of topics especially
if you see it in other platforms like
Twitter that yeah that uh
Elon recently highlighted the shadow
Banning that was happening and in
general the censorship that was
happening on those platforms do you
think about the role
of centralized control which information
isn't or isn't made available through
search and discovery I'll be honest I
never really think about it so uh you
just you just try to make fun videos
that yeah more I'm kind of more In My
Own Lane but it's not like that I don't
just specifically think about I just
like a lot of stuff in general like I'm
just kind of In My Own Lane thinking
about my own stuff uh but you know now
you asked I'm curious what are your
thoughts on on YouTube and that kind of
stuff well I'm generally against
centralized
um censorship or Shadow Banning Shadow
Banning is the worst one because not
that the goal of creating a healthy
platform where you're having great
conversations and uh videos that are not
spreading misinformation that sounds
like an admirable goal but that's too
difficult of a job for a centralized
entity that's too big of a yeah and then
there's the Mis information stuff and
then there's also just like the videos
where they do something that causes uh
what what happened back in the the where
uh adpocalypse you know and a lot of
creators Revenue plummets because people
are are doing videos that advertisers
don't deem acceptable and then now all
these big advertisers are pulling and
the little guys are getting hit and
because adverage drop by 30 and the
person who just quit his job to go
full-time consecration now can't sustain
it so it's also it's like a lot of
different variables as well that makes
it so complicated well I think the big
thing is transparency especially around
Shadow Banning for for people I agree on
Shadow Banning uh you should be
transparent you should let people know
it it you know obviously there has to be
some type of controls people can't just
post whatever and so if you're pulling
those levers they should at least know
yeah so they know how uh how to improve
their content they can understand it
they can exactly uh if it's a wrong
Shadow Banning like it's a society that
we should not Shadow ban this kind of
content that means exactly you should be
publicly discussing it because if not
and if it's not known then it's just
kind of like well then who's pulling the
strings and like how do we know they're
not just manipulating things to get
whatever message they want out there and
silence other ones yeah and there could
be sort of in the background government
influence which is where actual freedom
of speech comes into play that the
government should not have any control
or be able to put pressure on censorship
of speech and it gets weird if none of
that is being there's no transparency
around it yeah let's see but to be fair
that's a huge responsibility the amount
of content that YouTube is uploaded on
YouTube that is shared by YouTube viewed
by you but even more of a reason why it
it would probably makes sense to be
transparent yeah because then people can
help fact check it that's right but that
that requires building a platform that
makes that easy right like uh
to to make fact checking easy to make
the like Twitter now has like being able
to share context and all that kind of
stuff that crowdsource it crowdsources
the way Wikipedia crowdsource it I mean
there's
it's right and then you open a random
Wikipedia article
but like you know people criticize
Wikipedia because there is a political
lean to the editors of Wikipedia and
then they get
there's some articles that definitely
have a bias to them and all that kind of
stuff it's a difficult problem it's a
difficult problem to solve that
ultimately as much as possible it would
be nice for the viewer to have control
of that versus the
The Entity that's hosting it so for the
viewer to decide yeah I'm just going to
make fun cool videos yeah yeah you know
let's go to Antarctica again how was
that how was going to you just came back
from Antarctica that was I watched the
video that was that was fun that was a
really fun video thank you
um
there's I mean there's a lot of things I
can comment about that but what was that
what was the hardest part of making that
video the hardest part was just getting
out there it's just so remote and you
know you land the plane on just this ice
Runway and it's so sketchy and then once
the plane takes off you're just there
and you're the most remote place in the
planet and it's it's just it's very
breathtaking I don't if you have the
chance to ever go to Antarctica I would
recommend it it was probably like the in
the video we climbed a mountain
um that wasn't named so we can name it
and like standing on top of that
mountain and just seeing kindling
nothing and because once you get outside
the outskirts and you get deep in
Antarctica there's no Penguins nothing
lives there at all
um and so there's just nothing in every
direction it's just snow and these crazy
beautiful mountains and some of them
sticking to the clouds and it was in the
um if you go during summer time the Sun
never goes down so the Sun's Up 24 7 and
it's just like spinning in circles at
the top of the planet or whatever it
looks like the top
um yeah you guys come with it several
times how beautiful yes and so it's just
yeah it's just very beautiful what about
shooting itself like the technical
aspects of shooting it oh I mean well so
somehow we lucked out one of the days it
was like the warmest day in like forever
that's been in Antarctica it's like it
was positive uh degrees but at certain
parts there's also like negative 20
negative 30 and that's where the cameras
you constantly have to be switching out
the batteries and heating them up and
like putting them basically in like your
pants or they'll just get way too cold
and uh we were prepared for much worse
but it ended up being much better than
we thought so for that video but in
general maybe some other challenging
videos how does how do you go from the
idea stage to the actual execution to
the final video what's can you take me
through like a full process of like
we're talking about some crazy wild
ideas today how do you go from that to a
final video where you click publish well
I mean obviously first things first you
gotta figure out the idea and then it
just depends I mean pick any video you
can think of on my channel I can take
you through it
uh
uh well what about the in a circle you
have to stay in a circle for uh 400 Days
yeah so for that one step one one of the
most popular yeah that video did really
well yeah so we
um problem is uh we have to this is
where you get really into the nuances of
the company because we have a lot of
videos going out you can't just in a
vacuum be like all right we're not doing
anything for 100 days we're only filming
this so Step One is we had to build an
independent crew that could actually do
that for 100 days that way everyone else
could keep working on the normal videos
and not just screw everything up yeah
um so step one you build that team okay
we got the team now what do we need well
to do this we need probably like 10
cameras at least rolling at all times so
uh we're probably gonna need to get a
trailer and hook up a bunch of storage
and stuff so to just carry the sheer
volume of footage we're gonna have and
so get a trailer set up the cameras go
on the field paint a circle now we need
a house go buy a house bring it out
there uh and then it's like oh wait I
think it'd be funny if I brought the
house in on the intro for yeah you know
find a crane that can lift up a house so
I can drive it in and drop it in the
intro and that's like an iterative
process where you're like okay this
would be funnier so this is not all up
front yeah it's like your ideally it
would be but as you kind of see things
you get inspired and then you think of
more and more uh and then this would be
better with a crane yeah it'd be better
if I dropped out of the house yeah that
was crazy that you decided to do that uh
so Fearless in the kind of crazy stuff
you're willing to do exactly what I'm a
broken record but whatever makes the
best video possible yeah that's that's
all you you focus on okay so uh what
about the delegation of like who gets to
what are the cameraman like the people
operating the cameras what uh who's
responsible for different things this is
like a distributed process like well
that's where whoever the lead cam would
be on that video would just decided that
one because we shot over 100 days we
didn't a lot of it was just Sean and the
guy who was in The Circle just vlogging
I'm just gave him a camera yeah and he
figured it out and then we'd have like
for him just set hours each day that I
can't remember would come so if he had
any content he needed extra hands
instead of just having someone on
standby 24 7. it made more sense to do
set hours nice
um and uh yeah it was it was hard but
you know it's funny and hindsight it
sounds so simple you know and I I guess
like the more because that one is
relatively simple I guess because it's a
low number of people yeah the hard part
about that is just the time right like
you know I checked in on them so many
different days and it's like an hour
here two hours or two hours there over a
hundred days adds up to be a ton of time
and and even then like you know if you
have a 10 person crew you know paying
them daily rates for 100 days it just
all that adds up what about like the 100
versus 100 100 uh adults versus the
other kids
was uh bringing that to life that seems
like exceptionally challenging yeah
basically the thought process was we did
100 kids or sorry 100 boys 100 girls
yeah people loved it honestly I didn't
think they'd like it as much as they did
video did really really well so the
second I saw that video was crushing I
was like all right we're doing it again
but last time we did it we did in our
studio so we built a a giant room put
100 girls in it sounds bad when I
explain it like this and then a gyrant
put 100 boys yeah and we're like after
100 hours which everyone has the most
people give them half a million dollars
so did well so we're like all right
we're gonna do it again so we threw out
all these different ideas it was like
100 football players versus 100
cheerleaders 100 this 100 that and uh
100 prisoners versus 100 cops just
craziest ideas and we settled on 100
Kids versus 100 adults
um and then the next step was like how
do we make it better the kids versus
adults are the sorry the boys versus
girls the first one we did was inside
and the problem was every time it was
night when we did these long time lapses
you couldn't see the Sun go up and down
so we're like okay this time I want to
do it outside that's why the cubes are
outside
um and instead of doing circles we want
to make them cubes and then you know as
figuring out do we want that yeah
there's just those videos came up at
least today as ones that are like really
complicated in terms of the audio in
terms of how yeah film it yeah that's
the problem we had a lot of audio issues
because uh in the first one we didn't
have a roof on it the second one there
was a roof so there's a lot of Reverb
which then in editing made it brutal
like half the shots weren't usable and
it really screwed us over so we had to
do a lot of frankensteining in the
editing to make up for basically my
ignorance so you mentioned that you were
surprised how well that that one did a
lot of creators talk about getting
depressed
when um
the videos don't do as well as they kind
of expect it there's the kind of feeling
you can get really worn out by that dude
yeah
um you do your yourself feel that and
also do you have advice for others that
feel this
um yeah it's weird because I am a
numbers guy but also it it used to it
used to very much especially when I was
like betting everything I had on a video
when it did bad I was devastating I'd
cry and I'd be depressed for days and it
really would have a severe impact on my
mood but I don't know now it doesn't
really matter it's uh if a video that's
bad I just look at it and I'm like oh
why'd this video do bad uh probably oh
there's a little retention dip there I
don't think people like the thumbnail
maybe we should switch it I just look at
it objectively unemotional and then just
move on and I feel like that's a much
healthier way of going about it so if a
Creator is listening like that is the
ideal way to
um respond to a video that's doing bad
just remove emotion from the equation
and just look at it and figure out how
you can search the next one is there
tricks to detect being able to detach
yourself from the from that because
because I in your case I mean that's
true for creators but in your case
there's like a lot of money on the line
yeah well there's videos yeah so much
time but no I mean you just I mean I
don't know the only real answer is it's
just the conscious effort you just have
to unemotionally look at the video
determine the problems and then move on
like there's there is no secret you know
what I mean it's just that's it's that
and if you really can't bring yourself
to do it then you're just screwed
honestly maybe you're not meant for this
game
okay so that's part of the development
as the Creator is like being able to be
a different longevity yes yeah you have
to unemotionally be able to look at
videos that flop and figure it out uh
because if not just getting you can not
every video can be a one out of ten and
so when a video does bad you know that
that just stress and depression it's
just gonna eventually get to you in the
long run so you said you've uh failed in
a bunch of videos
uh sort of taking them to completion so
what are some of the biggest fails yeah
weirdly enough as we've matured and
we've done this more we don't have that
problem as much especially that we're
getting into the multi-million dollar
budgets per video it's like failure is
not really an option anymore so I'm a
little more particular about what I do
but back in the day yeah like we would
do a video where we spent 24 hours on a
desert island and uh we filmed it did it
all and I just I didn't like it after
the edit so I just grabbed the voice and
we went back to the deserted island and
spent another 24 hours there and
refilmed it
um or uh could that have been caught and
prevented at the idea stage like where
like no it's a good idea it was just
poor execution to be honest when we were
out there it was hot we were we're just
like we all at one point just kind of
wanted to die it was just miserable so
how do we how do you avoid that these
days uh well I just thought it was a
little cooler to be honest and then we
had literally the amount of fun we had
in the video was like 10 times higher oh
interesting so you like there's some
practical details that you just learned
yeah I don't know what it takes videos
that where it's very hot or or it's on
water because I get super seasick it's
like a kind of like 10 things that if
they have these variables I'm down to do
it but my fun meter is not as high as
normal uh like we tried to SP um anytime
we do anything on a boat like when we
spent 24 hours of beer in a triangle or
when I tried to spend like which I
didn't get up but I try to spend like
100 hours at sea or whatever just like
on a raft it's just like I it makes me
want to throw up and I get so seasick I
can't even see straight but there are
just some videos that require me to be
on a boat so I just suck it up
um so when you spend months in creating
a video I know this is probably
stressful to some creators
uh like how much stress how do you feel
when you have to click publish uh video
no not much you're able to detach
yourself yeah again in Old me tons I
mean I'd be like scratching and nervous
and like my hands would be sweating like
to the point where I'm almost about to
puke I'm like I really hope people like
this but you know I don't know I think
that's just part of maturing it there's
different and as a content creator
there's different phases and uh you just
like once you get over the the fear that
you're just gonna wake up one day and be
irrelevant you know and you just you
know accept that like you believe in
yourself and you believe in your content
and that you can continue to be relevant
then you don't I don't know you kind of
it's a little bit easier to attach
yourself I guess and that's I it's a
much healthier place to be you can't do
this for 10 years if every little thing
just causes these huge emotional
reactions it's like that's why a lot of
creators go a little you know mentally
insane you know you have to get out of
that that game right because it really
messes with you we've talked about this
a little bit but how do you define and
how do you suggest others define success
some people success is retiring their
mom
is inspiring people and educating them
and you know whatever they're peaking
their curiosity
um for other people it's just quitting
their job so you have to self-reflect on
what your definition of success is
because I think a lot of creators kind
of don't really think don't introspect
like they kind of want to keep getting
more and more subscribers kind of thing
and yeah but subscribers is just a
vanity metric you know it doesn't
subscribers don't correlate to views
sure or views what yeah I know but
that's more that was a drag to you that
was more direct to people listening
because uh a lot of people do really
care about subscribers or even followers
like on Tick Tock but if you look like
your view if on YouTube very very few
percent if even a percent of your views
come from the sub feed right you know
they're almost all home features
suggested what's the last time you
clicked on your sub feed to watch a
video oh almost never yeah yeah maybe
five years ago it used to be a thing
it's not anymore no one does
um and it's getting harder and harder to
find I subscribe to way too many
channels I think yeah that's what
everyone does and you subscribe to 10
channels they're great but two years
later your taste evolves and it's like
it's a mess and so
um subscribers don't really matter
followers on Tick Tock don't really
matter
um so anyways it really they really are
the definition of a vanity metric and
but what about views they do obviously
because if people are showing up time
and time again that's what matters okay
so that
that's a good thing to uh Define a
success I just feel like um that too can
be a problem
because uh
I would say you know if I wanted to be
successful like it's a young Creator I
might start copying Mr Beast or
something like that right yeah like
there's you start trying to take
shortcuts as opposed to find your your
own unique voice right so like chasing
views is a problem too it feels like or
no
um it's as long as you detach yourself
from them I mean if you're
lazy yeah and you just want to copy
someone else and not experiment and find
your own way but yeah I mean you can't
make that excuse for them and someone
just
isn't coming up with original stuff and
putting in the effort you can't just say
oh it's because they're chasing views we
need some different metric from the
chase no they just need to find their
own way well it just feels like unique
type of content will often lead to
sacrifice in the number of views in the
short term by the long term you win
okay or if you do win you you win more I
guess would be a better way putting it
do you think you will IPO miss Mr Beast
burger or feastables in the next five
ten years Beast burger or feasible snow
I I kind of think they're something
actually you know what I just realized
that this is our first time talking
about those we're like an hour and a
half in that's so funny we started
talking about what uh my retention brain
kicked in
um I wonder if you have retention brain
for like life itself I do every time I'm
talking to someone I can I'm like okay
what about like loved ones like spending
time with loved ones thinking like we
could be doing something much better
right now yes no that is a serious
problem uh with well so we'll pause the
b square question yes but that's why uh
my current girlfriend uh which I was
telling you before when we were talking
about this is she has a genuine love for
Learning and that's something I have
like I always feel like I need to be
learning something to justify the time
I'm spending and so that's why it's such
a nice trait because I feel like that
time is being used optimally because
whether we're watching a documentary or
we're going in in you know taking an IQ
tests or reading about whatever just why
Modern Art is the thing I don't know
whatever weird thing we decided to do
I'm always learning and improving so it
justifies the time so to maximize
retention in your relationship
yeah you want to spend time with that
time learning as much as possible yeah
which conveniently I don't have to force
right or I want to be recharging so I
when I do work I can you know hit the
ground harder and luckily we're into a
lot of the same things which you know
happen to be learning sometimes it's not
learning like maybe watching an anime or
something like that
um but I'm a big believer and you're
either if you well
if you if your goal is to be like a
super successful entrepreneur you need
to either be working or you need to be
doing something that decompresses and
recharges you so you can work again if
your goal is to be like a really
Kick-Ass entrepreneur obviously we're
boiling this down to like a very basic
thing and so the the things you're doing
your down time when you're not working
if it doesn't recharge you you're
screwed you're just a ticking time but
I'm waiting to implode
um and so you gotta like heavily
recharge and like so like watching for
me anime or whatever it is playing a
board game like that is actually kind of
crucial to my success which takes a lot
of maturing to come to that conclusion
because I used to be the kind of guy
that wanted to work every hour of the
day and I would try to train myself to
not need that stuff and I you know and I
almost resented like that I I have to do
these kinds of things and it would piss
me off because it's not optimal and you
know I just really want to make content
and entertain people but yeah as someone
who's gone down that road and you know
you just work every day for two three
months straight and you know every hour
of the day and then you just a bomb
waiting to explode and lose your mind
and the only real sustainable thing is
to just like give yourself time to
recharge in between working
so there's a kind of balance you have to
find you have to even and I hate it more
than anyone else because I you know you
hate not working yes because it's just
not optimal for time like it's it's it's
as a human I do need to occasionally
watch a Mindless show and play a board
game yeah and it took me a very long
time to like come to peace with that and
not I would have like borderline panic
attacks when I do it because I just what
am I doing right now why am I doing this
I should be you know like what if one
day I have to lay off an employee
because we're not doing so well like how
could I justify watching this this show
or whatever I'm doing right now you know
it's like there's a lot of things like
that that go on in your head but it's
necessary before we return to uh Mr
Beast burger
what is like is this one on the topic
what is a perfect day in the life
perfectly productive day in the life of
Mr Beast look like
oh boy well I mean or like a stand I
mean the perfectly productive day as we
filmed my main Channel video because
those get 100 million a pop I mean it
doesn't really get any better than that
what about like the average day when
you're not on the set yeah and you're
like because you're running a lot of
things right yeah so right now we have
our snack brand feastables we have a
restaurant chain piece burger and then
we basically which we haven't even
really launched any products yet but we
have the the data company that I was
showing you where we're gonna roll out
some tools for creators and then we have
the reacts channel the gaming channel
the main Channel and then we have my
charity which also has a channel
um and so kind of how I've structured my
life right now uh is whatever I have
free time we just kind of go hey guys
Jimmy's got an hour from 2PM to 3 P.M
and it's everyone's just like I need
this I need this and this Channel's like
I need this thing filmed or you know
whatever the guy who runs my tick tocks
like I need this Tick Tock filmder
um you know Beast Burger is like I need
this menu item approved do we need to
talk about this marketing thing and then
we kind of just look at what everyone
needs and we're like that one looks like
the most important we'll do that and
then so it's just kind of like you know
if I just did that for every company in
a day then that's optimal if I just kind
of like an optimal day for me would be
going down the eight companies and just
whatever they're like two to three
biggest pain points or things to need
from me and just doing those based on
priority and then trying to keep it as
short as possible yeah to just the
things that you're needed on it doesn't
get more optimal than that if I clear
the bottlenecks or some bottlenecks for
all my companies then it's yes that's a
perfect day yeah I mean even just me
because you're like you're showing me
around and you're being a great and
gracious host but on top of that you're
just doing all these meetings you you
basically I felt bad at some points I
was like oh I just tricked him into
going to meetings with me he's like my
little meeting buddy yeah I mean it was
it was fun it's fun to see it it was fun
to see how
effectively you've delegated
you basically trust the team to do a
really good job on the various things
and there's just a strong team that's
able to
carry the five on all the different
tasks yeah from the from the
brainstorming and the main channel to
the reacts and so on yeah it's really
interesting I mean it's it's really
interesting what it takes to build a
team like that because you very quickly
build the very large team that's that's
able to scale which is very scary
because it's my first you know I I'm 24.
you know and I think I was telling you
this earlier it's funny because six
years ago I had to raise my hand to go
use the bathroom and now I'm in charge
of hundreds of people and entertain
hundreds of millions of people and so it
is crazy just how quick it comes up and
I wish I was a little bit older so I
could have ran a couple companies and
failed a few companies in the past and
like learn from those and apply those
here because I know for a fact when I'm
34 I'm 24 now when I'm 34. I'll I'll
know so much more about running a
business and scaling and hiring and and
how to lead people and better
effectively communicate and all these
different skill sets that will make them
a better leader that uh that's the only
thing that sucks is uh I just don't have
those because I just haven't been
through the lessons and I just have such
a lucrative thing on my plate right now
and it just sucks that I have to learn
the lessons with the lucrative thing you
know what I mean yeah because you you
already have so much influence so much
impact but you have effectively scaled
what what lessons do you draw from that
how to effectively scale as a 24 year
old like yeah that's something I feel
like I actually could give a lot of
value to to young people who are doing
it like older people who've built five
companies or whatever they do
um I probably couldn't you know they're
gonna be like oh this is so obvious but
um for uh younger first-time business
owners you kind of just experiment to be
honest and uh but for us like it's just
a new space no one had really ever
skilled up a 100 person team to build
make content on YouTube so there wasn't
no uh I spent all this time like I hired
one person from Disney to at one point
to come in and help and obviously that
was a dumb idea looking back on it but
you know I thought oh they make great
stuff people want to watch and they come
over here and help me build a team and
you know they build it more the
traditional way and not like how it
should be online and and so then it's
like okay and now I'm not trying to
trash people like they all tried their
best but then I try hire this one person
who does this different type of uh media
and runs a 100 person team and then you
come in here and they try to build it
that way they don't really listen to you
or value or or see the difference and I
I tried basically for building this
company with like four or five different
people who worked in different veins of
media and you know every single time it
just like they just don't get it and
they like they don't understand my world
and the the eventual solution was just
like throw up my sleeves and do it
myself you know with like James where I
hit man and just like no no one's ever
done this and like No One's Gonna just
give us a golden carrot and tell us how
to build this company we got to figure
the [ __ ] out ourselves and you have to
kind of build up people from scratch
then yeah exactly all the stuff I was
talking about earlier and all the the
lessons I learned along the way
um and Sophie for me that was a big part
of like and try to stop trying to have
someone build this company for me and
just do it myself because it's scary
like my whole life studying YouTube
videos of virality not business building
but [ __ ] I was like I guess we just got
to do it ourselves and
um and that's where things really start
to click and we got the exponential
growth we started getting the right
people and training them the right way
and you know just throwing conventional
stuff out the door and focusing on
what's actually practical for YouTube
which is just completely different than
traditional media
so you train people and then those
people train people and and so on yeah I
mean it's just even like you know how
you do the lighting on sets or like how
you do the audio or or um you know not
writing scripts so you know we're just
not as efficient with our filming like
sometimes I have to have 30 cameras
running why because it's not scripted I
don't I don't know what Chris is gonna
do when we start filming he might run
over there but guess what we got to have
it planned because there's only one shot
I can't you know tell them not to do
that yeah that's the shooting but then
there's also the editing yeah and then
the editing as well and not having
guardrails and kind of you know I at the
end of the day it's whatever I want the
video their job is to make a video that
they think I'll like because it's my
channel but you know you can achieve
that kind of however and
um and so it's just everything's just
different you know it's much more I
guess like a startup as opposed to
um are you often surprised like with the
result like
you think a certain like we watched the
video today that was really nice those
different than you would have
potentially edited yeah are you
sometimes surprised by like a decision
editor makes it's like okay that's not
the way I would have done it but it's
actually this is a cool idea yeah of
course yeah now um the thing my biggest
fear is I don't ever want to get trapped
in like a bubble of you know because we
are getting 100 million views of video
on the main Channel like but I don't
want to get in this feedback loop of
just my ideas are great or or not
feedback loop but stop learning and
improving because it is easy sometimes
to be like what we're doing is working
we need to just keep doing it I want to
keep learning and trying new things and
I guess one way I'd put is like you
don't when when you're on a a come up or
you're growing you don't want to uh Test
new things once uh you start to Plateau
or have a downtrend because if you're
like you know you you're skyrocketing
right you're up up and then you level
off you start to go down and you're like
oh this isn't working anymore let's
start experimenting well if you have a
bad experiment now you're in like a
tailspin you're nose diving and you have
one more bad experiment you're like
screwed kind of I'm oversimplify you
want to test things while you're still
growing to keep the growing from
happening because once you like have you
know again very oversimplifying that
like you know kind of level off you do a
couple tests that go wrong am I you're
like screwed you know you're already out
the door now you're just confirming that
you're out the door an online
entertainment so that's kind of how I
see it so I think it's very imperative
that you're constantly always
experimenting and trying things even if
you're getting crazy unheard of growth
and so that outside of the thing
that brought you to the dance you just
dived right into uh Mr Beast burger and
feastables this is a whole nother
industry like what was that like well so
Beast Burger we kind of it was supposed
to be like just a pop-up like we just
partnered with someone who had 300
restaurants and we're just like you know
um let's let's just uh sell Beast
burgers for a day or two let's let's see
what happens we didn't really think it
would be as big as it was but those
first like that first day you know we do
six figures in sales and they all sell
out and they're running to local
Walmarts they can't keep up with the
demand and it's like okay well maybe
let's just leave it open a week whatever
um and we're just doing crazy revenue
and it's like okay well let's add some
more restaurants and let's just leave
them open for a month and we're just
still doing six figures a day and it
kind of just went from this thing that
was
I don't know it wasn't really I don't
really plan on running a restaurant
chain but here I am but didn't that in
some sense also open your mind to
something like festivals feasible is
something I've always wanted to do
because I I think just in general uh
American snacks are just full of so much
horrible ingredients to be honest and
they're not I don't know I feel like
there also just hasn't been any
innovation in American snacks in quite a
while
um and so that's just something I've
always been pretty passionate about the
thing we built that from scratch so we
hired the CEO and built a team around
them and we we spent probably over two
and a half years before we even launched
just like building the right team
figuring things out and making sure it
was actually ran the way I wanted
um which feasible has just been crushing
it's
it's very interesting uh this is
something I've never talked about
publicly but having products in retail
it's like before feastables everything I
had done was online so if you wanted to
you know anything from the cocoa peace
brand you'd have to buy it online and
ship it to you but feastfuls now that
you know because our first product
chocolate bars we started putting that
in retail locations so like for example
Walmart it's it's crazy like it's just
it doesn't make sense how if you're
which I guess it does for because we get
100 million views of videos so a lot of
people know us if I go stand in Walmart
those people recognize me and ask for
photos like if I still don't enough I
could take 150 photos today in Walmart
200 whatever it is so obviously it makes
sense those people go find feastfuls but
then you just multiply that by every
Walmart in America and it just gets so
crazy and I didn't think we'd be doing
the kind of Revenue we are and we're
about to launch in some other I don't
know if I'm allowed to say so whatever
but other big retail you know locations
and convenience stores and like by the
end of next year we could be in like 40
fifty thousand locations and the numbers
just don't make sense so you know what
are some interesting challenges about
scaling there that surprised you the
biggest problem which I didn't think
would be was just keeping the shelves
and Walmart stock to be honest like it
would have to supply it was supply chain
it was brutal well even then sometimes
like you know you get them the stuff and
they're like it takes them like a day or
two to put it out in that specific
location and I I had to stop promoting
it because every time I'd mention it
like 40 of people would just be like
it's not there it's not in Walmart or I
can't buy it and so there's like a
three ish month period where I just
didn't promote festivals because I was
scared that someone would go by and this
is not there and so like it took us a
very long time to catch up to the demand
and also it's not like we have unlimited
money so but now we're relatively caught
up in
um keeping up but it's gonna be
interesting because now this year in
2023 we're gonna basically you know
10x the amount of locations they're in
so or and we're gonna try to launch new
products so we're in for an interesting
ride but yeah I just hate I hate when I
tell people you know like hey go try
this product and then they go in their
local Walmart and eventually other
places and it's not there it's just so
brutal you know they made that whole
journey out there and they didn't get it
and so that that was really it
um
besides that no it's it's been doing way
better than I ever thought
uh you've talked to a couple places
about maybe doing mobile games or
computer games in the future yeah yeah
is that something you're still
considering yes
um because uh you know do you normally
talk with people as much as we talked
beforehand is that no no that that was
the pro who spent all day today look in
my head everything you asked me is stuff
we already talked about not really well
no no not everything I take it back but
sorry the last two questions yes and so
it's just funny because what no I tried
it's okay there's a different style of
asking those questions because I I on
purpose didn't dig further with you uh I
could tell yeah so I can tell you okay
this is by the way okay all right well
this is the first time I've ever talked
to somebody
as much as I did with you
beforehand yeah well on the same day I
know we're not even saying okay together
one hour yeah
literally it's funny
um this is a hilarious and awesome
social experiment I think I picked this
hotel and I just like harassed him all
day to hang out with me and then great
here we are now I love it
um I was secretly recording the whole
time just you know I'm just kidding
anyway so what was the question
yeah so the interesting thing is uh with
Beast burger and feastables that um
there's physical Goods as opposed to
like making mobile games or PC game
whichever one we end up doing which is
software and I actually have a giant
International audience like
um most of my audience is obviously
outside of America and so the problem
we're running into is it just takes time
to build up the supply chain and get
feastables in Southeast Asia get
festivals in India get festivals in
Brazil and Mexico and all these other
places where we have giant pockets of
our audience and same thing with
peaceful it's just it's going to take
probably years uh unless we partner with
someone who already has the distribution
which we're figuring out but the UDF
software is I can make a hypothetical
game or whatever we end up doing and all
my fans can you know use it tomorrow the
day I mentioned it and so if I promote
something in a video to 100 million
people and it's like uh you know
basically like a game they can all
download it so there you know
um but if I promote a feast rules bar
right now it's only in America because
we're struggling just to keep up with
American demand we haven't even gotten
the chance to go outside America so I I
alienate I'm uh a majority of my
audience and it feels so shitty to just
from you know mention something that
most of them can't buy but on the flip
side you can't just spawn this crazy
infrastructure and just have tens of
millions of bars and all your products
in every single store across the world
before you promote it so you can't put
the egg before the chicken and so
um it's like that that's that's what I'm
excited about I want to get into less
physical stuff and more stuff that
everyone matters can actually use this
is the thought process especially if
there's a social element to the gaming
too because it's not unlike feastables
like that's a product you consume you
missed it when you're setting it for
this we were uh doing some basically
just laying out every everything that
we're planning for so our interfaces
where we want to start hiring the team
to build it and we're kind of just
laying out the game and I was actually
really curious to get your thoughts but
I can't say it because whatever I say
someone's just gonna take it and run
with it but you're pretty good idea
about the kind of games you're thinking
about yeah I mean I can imagine we also
talked a little bit about it it's super
awesome good one I did so much good talk
all right the juicy talks having you
she's like I gotta go set up well you
know I I already heard a lot awesome I
mean but that is a different kind of
team you would need to hire yeah is that
a little uh nerve-wracking like going
into a new field and trying to a little
bit but then I remind myself like like
Steve Jobs didn't know how to code right
and you know he just he just knew what a
good product was and I feel like as
someone who wasted so much of his lives
playing video games I have a good sense
of it and that might be ignorance well
that's really important right it's not
about coding it's about what makes for a
good game exactly and again that might
genuinely be ignorant so maybe I end up
you know getting bit in the butt because
of what I'm saying now but I think just
like with YouTube I just want to obsess
over making a great product and things
that I think my audience will love and I
think as long as I keep that as my North
Star will do well
uh what is the path to being worth 100
billion look like
doesn't have to be worth 100 billion
look like I don't know because okay okay
let me just like pause here 24 and
there's so much awesome scaling so many
great ideas you you think about
different trajectories yeah uh what
those possible trajectives might look
like
yeah I mean if the goal was to just be
worth 100 billion dollars yes I'm my
goal of a broken record so make the best
view impossible because I know whatever
else I want will come obviously the
video is the foundation yeah exactly so
to Pat to 100 billion dollars just keep
getting 100 million views of video you
know what I mean
um but or more oh yeah or more exactly
if we can keep growing but you know if
we can
keep feasibles growing right and we
eventually spend International and one
day we're in 100 000 retail locations
and we're selling the same amount of
excuse or units per skews like we're
currently doing uh I mean that would
crush and then obviously ideally one day
we open up hundreds of Beast Burgers we
get it where we turn out you know like
supercell a couple hit games I don't
want to make dozens or hundreds of games
I just want to make games that are just
great and you know we rarely drop them
while we do they're bangers
um and just you know whatever other
stuff we end up doing all that combined
I mean it's just interesting because
like what what's a show that's pulled
100 million views per episode basically
that's like we're doing like you know I
mean like the Super Bowl gets praised
because they get 100 million viewers but
I can't think of a show
um maybe in reruns or something so
there's also a show that's has uh has a
singular kind of figure yeah that you
can now use as a like I don't have a
network tell me what to do I don't have
anyone like I can do whatever I want so
it's a very interesting position because
I put out content and 100 million people
show up and then I also have a gaming
channel I put out content 15 million
people show up in a reaction I put out
content 10 million people show up and
have a tick tock and I put out content
and on average 20 million people show up
and like and I so as long as I can keep
that going and then we build these
businesses it's like it's honestly
pretty scary to see what will happen you
know uh over the years because
feastables launched you know last year
2022 so it's a relatively new thing and
Beast Burger we just started scaling up
the physical side and we haven't
obviously even launched any mobile games
yet so I think I'm at the antithesis of
it I don't see a world where my YouTube
channels are relevant in the next couple
of years I just this is what I live for
and so if I can keep that going and then
really start to expand these businesses
that leverage off of it then yeah I mean
hopefully there's the day one where I
could give away a billion dollars in a
video honestly that that yeah that would
be one hell of a video
um let me ask you the ridiculous
question since you went from being broke
to being uh Rich although you keep
uh spending all your money
um but uh does money buy happiness how
has money changed sort of your
your happiness in life it's money by
happiness
um
no not I mean to a point yes once you
can take care of your health you can
take care of like any immediate dangers
and you can take care of your family
relatively no it doesn't like but those
things do like when I first came into
money one of the first things I did was
retire my mom and like that brought me
tons of happiness you know what I mean
and like you know if my brother had a
medical emergency and and we couldn't
afford it and I made money to afford it
that would bring tons of happiness you
know so once you take care of those
basic necessities so we'll say makeover
hypothetically a million dollars no it
it really doesn't like adding an extra
zero going from 10 million to 100
million or whatever it is makes no
difference
so you're given that or just fearless
and spending the money yeah well let me
reframe I guess it could for some people
if if you really
I don't know you spent your whole life
obsessing over cars it probably would
bring you a little bit of joy to buy a
nice Lamborghini I I'm coming more from
the frame of mind of of an entrepreneur
someone who's really obsessed with
business ability for me and a lot of my
friends and people I hang around what
brings us happiness is winning and
building companies and do you know
changing the world like that that is fun
it's a complex problem you can wake up
every day and it gives you something to
obsess over and devote your life to
where it's just having money doesn't you
know well one interesting question for
you psychologically so because you
have become wealthy and because you give
like part of your work is giving away a
lot of money
um do you find it hard to find people
you can trust
is do people see you basically as a
source of money as opposed to another
human being it's weird because you would
think yes but I I feel like I also know
the right places to look
um but yeah if I just walked into Target
and try to make friends with 10 random
people of course
um you gotta
uh so you can kind of sense oh yeah
that's the right thing yeah that's yeah
it's so obvious so I don't even want to
go into descriptions but honestly a lot
of my friends are like uh Chandler I I
played literally with him
um and Tyler the guy I mean I went to
school with him Chris he was my first
subscriber
um Carl was here after we got big but
whatever he's friends with the boys and
it is a lot of my closer friends even
like my YouTube friends I I knew before
I was big so
maybe there is some mirror to that maybe
it is I I don't know I've never really
put too much thought into it maybe
there's a reason I hang around a lot of
these people I knew before I got paid
because it's much easier and they help
you keep like uh your radar sharp of who
can and can't be trusted because you
know you can trust them yeah it's
difficult when you become richer and
richer and more powerful well one day
one time when you get rich oh yeah not
even richer but more fan one thing I
thought is as I climbed this like ladder
of YouTube and got bigger I thought
there would be tons of people like me
people
how to like that takes like the Kamikaze
approach to building a business you just
throw all your money in it you throw all
your time you throw all your energy
throw everything yeah you're just like
[ __ ] it this is this I'm dead yeah I
thought there would be hundreds of these
yeah and and there isn't there is I mean
there's like maybe one or two and I
talked to those [ __ ] every
single day I'm sick and tired of talking
to them but I love them
um but it's just so interesting because
like every level I got up like I get a
million subscribers like all right
where's all these guys in the million
subscribers that are [ __ ] Psychopaths
and then you know you know there are
people become like conservative as they
get like they get more especially as
they get bigger yeah and you know 20
million subscribers 30. it's like every
step of the way it's like I just got
more and more lonely to be honest since
you you know it sounds cliche and you
hear that kind of [ __ ] in movies and
you're like that's not how it works but
it is like there's there's just not many
people that just want to give up
everything go all in and obsess over
making the greatest goddamn videos every
single day of their life like they're
really hard to find and be able to
sacrifice everything for that video yeah
like basically you put all the money
right back in yeah or the people doing
it they're on just a small scale and if
I talk to them it's just 99.9 of the
time I'm teaching them things and it's
like so it's lonely because there's not
too many people especially in the
creative space that are as crazy as you
yeah it is 100 it's it's so it's not
what I I was expecting I was expecting
there'd be a lot of people like me but
well I guess the guy would talk to Elon
Musk is a bit like you in that sense
yeah just in a different domain yeah
yeah exactly just willingness to put it
all back in right and that's why I found
right now a lot of the people I relate
to don't even make YouTube videos like
they're just like I'm viewing more and
more away from fellow content creators
and more to just you know I'm just
looking for those other people who just
share a little bit of it so I don't feel
so [ __ ] crazy all the time like you
know what I mean
um and like people I feel normal around
and they tend to just be doing the
randomest things but you know loving it
well I think that's really inspiring
it's uh
it's like the Bukowski line to find what
you love and let it kill you is really
put everything
put everything into the thing you love
that that's like the way to really
create special stuff but it's also the
way to yeah
you have to be careful given this advice
because
they're like they're like bodybuilders
who'll be like just go to the gym be
disciplined I'm disciplined go to gym
but I would argue for those people it's
like it's not even discipline they just
enjoy weightlifting right because there
are people who are jacked but they don't
make much money or run a business right
if they're that disciplined they would
they would be hitting every area of
their life they just really like
business and there's people like me who
just to an extreme level love building
companies right it's not even discipline
for me it's just in my blood it's what I
wake up I don't think about it I don't
push myself I don't need to watch a
[ __ ] motivational video to go work I
just do it it's programmed in me at this
point and I couldn't imagine a world
where I don't wake up and do it every
day
um but I think that a little bit of it
is genetics
um and just how you're hardwired uh not
that it can't be trained or taught and
not that you know and obviously the
friend group you're in influences these
things and over time I think can change
it but someone's just not gonna be able
to flip a switch and then just start
doing a kamikaze approach to building a
business just like a lot of people try
to flip a switch and start bodybuilding
and quit majority of the time you know
that's just not innate to them but I
think a lot of us have the capacity to
do that in some domain yeah I think if
you went about strategically if you
surrounded yourself with fellow
like-minded people and you know slowly
over time switched it uh but if you just
try to like hardcore do it you're just
going to lose your mind
do you ever worry about your mental
health did you take step to protect it
to uh
yeah to like for the long run to make
sure you have the mental strength to go
on yes weirdly enough the best thing for
my mental health was giving in to my
innate nature to work and the most
depressed I get is when I try to
restrict it and like I don't work
weekends so I don't work this day what's
best for me is just to work when I feel
like working and then just not work when
I don't like and just have no
constraints because there are just some
nights where I don't want to sleep and
for whatever reason I feel compelled to
go all night whatever like just do it
you know do whatever you want it's what
I tell my like working brain
um and I just give in to it and I feel
that's where I feel the happiest and and
then um you know it's typically like
when I'm really in The Grind Mode it'll
be like seven or eight days it's just
non-stop going going and then it's like
oh I'll realize like oh I need some
recharge time and then go [ __ ] binge
a season of anime yeah but listen here
but that's the thing like people will
tell you don't work weekends or don't do
this or don't work past this or blah
blah give you all these constraints but
for me and it's unconventional I just
give into it I think there's something
really to be said for that I I try to
surround myself with people that like
what I don't when I pull an all-nighter
they don't go like you should get more
sleep there's a reason I pulled that
all-nighter like if I'm really
passionate about something they say they
basically encourage it because I I have
no problem getting sleep and getting
rest
um what I need in my life is people that
encourage you to kind of keep going keep
going with the thoughts that you're
passionate about normal people They
don't want that life and they probably
shouldn't it's not good for you
um but yeah is if you hang around people
like just whatever different people
you're gonna feel crazy and it's gonna
wear on you whereas if you're around
similar people it just it's so much
easier like if you
you know
um I've started weightlifting more and
like one thing that's helped is just
having Jack people around me because
they naturally just eat healthier they
do like they naturally just have
freaking grilled chicken and all this
[ __ ] and high protein meals and it's
just like easier for me to just
piggyback and be like oh can you just
order me whatever you're getting uh and
they're like I gotta go to the gym and
I'll be like oh [ __ ] I'll just join you
you know and it's like it's just it's
cheat codes you know I mean just
surround yourself with people that you
want to be and it makes it like 70
easier in my opinion it's like that is
the cheat code to life
um and I wish I obviously your audience
is definitely a lot older but you know
to the older people listening like if
you have are in a place of mentorship
for someone younger or have influence
over younger people you should really
try to drill that in their heads like
the people are there around 100 dictates
the outcome I would not be on 120
million subscribers if I didn't find uh
when I was around a million I had a
couple friends that were just also
Psychopaths you know I outgrew them but
at the time it was great and I wouldn't
be where I am today if it wasn't for
them
um and just all along the way the
friends that I hung out with had such a
dramatic impact on wearing them like I'd
probably have 80 million less
subscribers you know if it was if I
wasn't so strategic about hanging out
with people that I add value to and they
also add value to me so the advice for
young people would be to
be very selective about the people you
saw yourself so selective it's it's
crazy like Chris you know he's I I he's
really funny and that's why he's great
for the videos and part of why he's so
funny is he consumes copious amounts of
cartoons and just funny content and so
I'll find like when I spend more time
with Chris I'll start just quoting these
weird cartoons and shows and like my
speech will literally change and just
after like a week of spending more time
with them it has like it's like that
quick enough effect you know now picture
that over the course of years I mean
yeah it has such a huge influence like
pluck one of their friends out and
hypothetically put me in there and yeah
you know there's no doubt if they're
trying to become a content creator there
are odds of success is 10x right
obviously you can't do that but you got
to find your closest version of it and
just be selective yeah but this also
applies not just to younger to older
people to agree but they it's it's even
more I like when I was a teenager I just
you know I couldn't relate to many
people I just I was like a [ __ ]
freaking nature because no one was
obsessed with building businesses or any
of this kind of stuff and so like back
then you know that advice would have
been helpful maybe not that particular
but just knowing that there are you know
it's not that you're a freaking nature
you just haven't found people that have
the same interests so the task is not to
feel sorry for yourself or somehow
change yourself it's more to finally
find people you fit in with yeah yeah
assuming which you know you're not
getting comproment uh like assume it's
not something bad right like if your
hobby is shooting things you know or
shooting things you shouldn't be
shooting you know don't find people that
encourage that but
outside of that for sure uh actually as
an answer to what is the best advice
someone ever gave you you said you're
crazy until you're successful then
you're a genius 100 all along the way
people gave me so much
you know advice on why I shouldn't be
doing it why I'm crazy every step of the
way people wanted to tell me why I
shouldn't be doing this and should get
alive should stop being too obsessed
everything everything under the book
um and then once I'm successful those
same people are like tank
you're a genius wow you really you
pulled that off those are probably the
same people that will give you advice
now you're the most successful video
creator of all time stick to that
anytime you want to do something new
right yeah uh they'll they'll like
pressure you not to do the um
you know feastables or or mobile gaming
or whatever lays Beyond yeah it's funny
how people don't well honestly they're
the type of people I just don't talk to
anymore
I don't even know what they have to say
now so most people on the team are like
yes and they're like whatever the idea
you got they they're with it no it's
weird we actually have a my team pushes
back on me pretty hardcore which I want
I don't want Yes Man and yeah they're
they're like uh they're James you know
the CEO who helped me build all this um
he's very adamant like we're not yes men
and and he trains people to really think
for themselves and even when I give them
orders like really think like is this
optimal is there context or information
Jimmy could be missing that I can
provide that could help him make a more
updated decision like I'm not
um God you know what I mean like I'm
human I make errors and so don't take
what I say that's the Bible
so even like in the brainstorming and so
on they can they can push back yeah you
can see it like Tyler anytime I said
something he would give me feedback and
push back which is what I want I don't
want him just to be like yes you're
[ __ ] genius good job Jimmy you know I
don't need that you know I need
negatives
uh
you talked about being in a relationship
what role Jimmy does love playing The
Human Condition
I think
well roll this well the big thing is
love can be scary because this is you
know the human you're gonna spend the
most amount of time with in your life
you know and so for projected over 50
years they can be a liability or an
asset I love the magic tricks you know I
love no but seriously it's got to be
someone that makes you better for me I
can't truly love someone that doesn't
make me better because yeah in the long
run yeah across across because if not
then it's like it's a negative you know
to everything I've spent my life
building yeah um but luckily I'm very
happy with the the partner I haven't
like we were talking about before I do
think she makes me better there's a lot
of actually positives I've noticed even
things as simple as like you know I
struggle to turn off my brain at night
because I'm just thinking about all the
businesses and how we could do better or
whatever weird thing I have on my mind
but you know just chatting with her and
hanging out with her helps me like
basically just shut my brain off and
like mellow out and even like there's
just a ton of little things like that
that I've noticed are positives
especially when you really look for them
that are easy to gloss over if you're
not
um and so for me yeah I have someone who
I think it's very beautiful very
intelligent makes me better it's
constantly pushing me okay with me
working hard makes me smarter and just
all these different things that I think
for me love
just makes me a better person you know
what I mean which makes me love her even
more does that make sense absolutely
what advice would you give on uh finding
somebody like that
um
just really don't give up until you you
find someone that you know there's so
many people on the planet I mean there
really is there there's billions of the
odds are in your favor of yeah like just
don't settle and find someone that you
know makes you happy
yeah just like you said surround
yourself with people that make you a
better person in the same case surround
yourself with that one special person
that really makes you a better person
and for and maybe that's just an
entrepreneurial brain looking at it not
everyone's to hyper optimize their life
like me but for me to like truly love
someone they have to make me a better
person in every way yeah yeah
well what do you hope you're 24. we
thought we started talking about death
let's let's finish talking about death
what do you hope your legacy is when you
when we look a hundred years from now
and yeah alien the AI has completely
taken over and the aliens visit and
discuss with the AI what this last of
special humans that existed on Earth was
like what what do you hope they say
about you
um
it's a deep one as
probably just that because it's hard
right like I said before Elon is over
double my age I could live every second
I've lived up to this point in my life
and still have elon's age so I have so
much time I just hope whatever it is
that it's a net positive on the world
and it impacts billions of people in a
positive way that makes lasting change
so you admire people like Steve Jobs and
Elon Musk for having
sort of reached for that goal as well
yeah of course to help to help Millions
I mean the iPhone's the most successful
product ever invented it's hard not to
admire what he created you know
um the same with sort of as Johnny Ive
talks about like the the passion the
effort they put into the designing the
iPhone that like little bit of love is
transferred to the whole world like they
get to experience the joy of that from
the designer it's what a beautiful thing
to do you know I mean I couldn't think
of anything better you know to create
something that even after you're dead
for decades just has such a
profound impact on basically half the
human population yeah it's wild brings
joy to people yeah um well I hope you do
just that man you've already done it for
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people and I hope you keep
doing it I'm ex I can't like it's so
exciting to see what happens this year
and next year I know like this is the
limit yeah I can't I mean uh the videos
but ever all the other businesses you're
in and you as a human being as you grow
I can tell I know as everyone knows you
have a kind heart and the fact that
you're really damn good at uh actually
using that kind of heart to help a lot
of people it's awesome to see man I
appreciate it more importantly before we
go yeah are we gonna play Dune tonight
it's important I'm gonna play dude I
have to I have you don't want one hour
you don't want to play board games with
me I wanna I'll play I'll play
four games
if if only I wasn't an idiot and
actually flew to the right airport yeah
I do more games with me they're gonna
dislike the video
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Mr Beast to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from the poet and philosopher
rabindranath tagore
reach high
for stars lie hidden in you
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time